Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Did you guys like your loops?
Welcome, welcome.
For those who don't know.
Also, yes, it's me.
Hi.
Hi, Toki.
Hi, dragons.
Hey.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the hype train, everybody.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Sorry, I'm like...
I guess every time when I swap from YouTube to Twitch, my mind also gets, like, a little bit jumbled up because I feel like, you know, I have to thank different things.
And, like, you know, because, like, Twitch and YouTube, they have different names for different things.
So, like, my mind is like, okay, is it a ship or a sub?
Hey, guys.
Hello, everybody.
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
I really didn't even finish my thanking for the subs.
But Marco, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
Mehdi, thank you for the 400 biddies.
Zero, thank you for the gifted sub to Evil.
Thank you.
Qtay, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Anonymous, thank you for giving tier 1 sub to Setsuna.
Hey guys, so for those who are wondering what am I doing on Twitch again, if you guys remember, I think it was like a week or two ago.
It was two weeks ago, I believe.
Um, we did a watch-along of the Samsung Galaxy Gear Up Cup presented by, uh, presented by and powered by Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
So we are here again, back here again, because what we watched last time was just the draft of the teams.
Now, it's the real tournament, the real finals cup, where they will be playing on a Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Uh, so a bunch of teams are actually competing right now.
Um, but we are watching the finals of the, I believe, the final two teams that will make it to the end.
And it is in, I believe, it is hosted in Las Vegas!
Viva Las Vegas!
Uh, but yeah, it's, I believe, I just found out, like, the Level Up, the, where it's hosted.
Because it's in, like, Level Up, right?
It's actually a really big, um, expo regarding, like, for gaming and, uh, for gaming.
And I saw, like, a lot of people, uh, a lot of, like, my artist friends were actually, uh, uh, dealing art stuff.
Uh, so, yeah, it's gonna be really interesting.
Like I said, it's all, it's Call of Duty Mobile.
So, they're all gonna be playing, and it's presented by Samsung.
So, um, uh, it's gonna be, like, all done on the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
So, it's gonna be very interesting, because they got a bunch of teams in together.
Uh, got four Call of Duty Mobile Pros, um, and 16 Call of Duty players.
And then put them together, and then we're gonna see who's gonna win 100k.
Uh, so, yeah, today is the finals day!
Woo!
Is the coach still in?
I assume they're all playing, right?
I mean, it's, like, how many, it's, uh, 5v5, right?
I assume they're all playing.
Wait, are the, I think the coaches are playing, right?
Yeah, because there's, like, one of the match-ups is, like, coach-v-coach match-up, and, um, and I don't think the coach, I don't, well, we saw how they did in the 1v1s against the other pros, but I believe he could, he could coach them better than the other teams.
So, since he does actually, I think he was, like, the only, the coach was, like, the only one that actually, like, looked at, like, that looked at the players.
And, like, you know, I remember the other captains were, like, like, he looks cool in this photo.
I remember that.
But then the coach, yeah, they were, like, picking Shirley off of vibes.
But then the coach was, like, well, I saw this stream, like, uh, yesterday.
And, like, he seemed to know what he's doing.
And because he seemed, and he seems to be really good at this certain gun.
And then you cut to the other, other captain.
And he's like, ah, he looked really cool in that photo.
Like, he's like, look at that aura.
So, I don't know.
Honestly, I haven't really, I didn't check up on, like, which team is currently winning so far.
But we will look into that a little bit later.
But yes, a huge shout out to Samson for presenting the Gear Up Cup, the Galaxy Gear Up Cup.
And, um, you guys already know about the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Um, if you guys forgot about, like, you know, some of the features it has.
It has, it's basically unmatched power.
So, um, it has the Snapdragon 8 Elite for Galaxy.
So, the most advanced processor for any Galaxy phone.
And so, there's a crazy fast performance and super smooth gameplay, even with the most demanding games.
So, this is, like, this, I can see, like, this tournament being, like, a good, like, stress test on, like, showcasing you guys what you can do with gaming on mobiles.
And I think, like, mobile gaming is, like, especially in esports, mobile gaming and esports is, like, getting more and more popular around the world.
And, you know, it is definitely a really good market going into it.
Um, so, this is a great way to present, like, how, you know, how, how well it performs with, in, um, in this tournament.
And then there's, like, graphics that pop.
So, it got pro scalar temp that boosts image quality by 40% and upgraded ray tracing.
So, it makes lighting shadows and reflections look insanely real in games that support it.
And then there's also a huge display.
So, it's 6.9 inch display.
Nice.
With barely any, uh, bezels.
Um, so, and it has a 120 hertz refresh rate.
So, like, you know, better than when I started gaming.
Um, uh, when I started gaming, I did not get to play on 120 hertz.
And that was on a laptop.
Uh, and it also is cool under pressure.
So, it has a large, larger vapor chamber and upgraded cooling system.
So, basically, you can play as long as you can and won't, like, you know, like, scorch your, scorch your legs or your, or your hands and stuff like that.
Um, and comfortable gaming anytime.
The S25 Ultra is slimmer, lighter, and has a rounded design that feels amazing in your hands.
So, no cramps on your hands.
That's, like, the one thing I, I'm always scared about when I game too long.
Um, is, like, the fact that, I don't know.
This is, like, every gamer's worst fear or, like, worst nightmare is when, if you game too much, you're gonna, you're gonna, like, you're, you would, like, you know, hurt your wrist or, like, spring your wrist and your arms.
You know what I was told?
Um, I was told that, um, I was told that, like, um, like, you know, it's, like, basically, like, the death sentence of, like, uh, of, like, pro players.
If you have, like, you know, if you, like, sprain your wrist or your, um, if your arm or anything regarding longer gaming sessions.
So, it's, it is nice to know that it does, there's no more, you don't really get hand cramps with the Galaxy S25 Ultra.
So, you don't have to worry about that.
You can do longer game sessions and everything.
Um, so, yeah, it is very, that's why I don't do long game sessions anymore on PC because it's, like, considered, it's, like, a career-ending injury.
Yeah.
So, uh, because, like, on PC, it's a lot scarier because you do use your, you know, you, it depends on your sense, too.
It depends.
I use, I use arm, I move my mouse via arm movement.
I don't do wrist because wrist is, like, a lot scarier regarding and more easily, you're more easily to, like, get, like, carpal tunnel syndrome with using your wrist more than your arm.
And I try to do stretches and everything.
Um, but that's why I try to avoid long gaming sessions, uh, or, like, back-to-back-to-back long gaming sessions where I have to aim a lot.
Uh, but yeah, so, I'm looking forward to seeing how much the team has improved for this tournament because I don't know if you guys remembered, but we didn't really see them play last time.
We only saw the coaches play.
So, I guess we're gonna see, like, um, how much they've improved in general and, um, and how much do they, have they, like, transitioned into mobile gaming and how well they're gonna do with that.
Uh, but yes, guys!
Woo!
Let me, let me, let me put the stream on real fast.
Also, let me know, let me know if the sound is okay because I didn't save the sound for last time.
All right.
Uh, let's get rid of... Oh, here it is.
Oh, you guys see it?
All right.
Let me know if the sound is okay.
I don't know if my sound guy is here.
Oh, yeah, but they're playing at the stadium right now, at the expo.
So, this is at, um, Level Up Expo in Las Vegas right now.
And they are competing for a hundred grand.
So, it, it's a lot of money.
It's a lot.
I mean, it's a hundred grand.
Like, imagine we could do...
With a hundred grand.
Wait, the captains are playing.
Wait, they are playing.
All right, I'll put the volume up a little bit.
Yeah, because it's 5v5.
I know Huskers.
I forgot how many people they, like, drafted in.
So, I wasn't, like, that sure if it was, like, if the coaches were playing.
Man, it kind of sucks when you're in a moment like this and you're like, Hey, talk about him.
Just say something bad.
Say something that is going to make you just do anything to stoke the flame a little bit.
And they're like, nah, he's dope.
We love him.
We're trying to farm content here.
What are they farming for?
Oh, wait, are they not there?
Oh, wait, they're not there yet.
They're just waiting for the last player.
Oh my god, flesh.
Oh, yeah, you guys want to know more about the tournament, um, and, uh, the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Uh, do exclamation point Samsung.
So convenient.
Huge shout out to my mods for setting all of this up for me.
It's been really cool to see everything going on around.
I'm glad that we're able to be a part of it.
Flesh.
We want to see the crowd.
I want to see the crowd.
85.
Ooh, 30,000.
Guys, what's 30,000 divided by five?
I'm actually serious.
What?
Guys, I'm not memeing.
What is 30,000?
Okay, 6K.
Thank you, guys.
You guys are my human calculator.
You guys are my human calculators.
Thank you.
I've boosted the volume a little up for...
All right, so that's 6K each.
Okay, yes.
And how many years have I been a streamer guy?
How many years have I been a streamer?
If you get the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra, you will also have your very own calculator in your hands.
Oh, they beat Notorious.
Wait, who is Notorious?
Which one was Notorious?
Is this the coach's team?
Oh, that's awkward.
Does anyone remember who was in Notorious's team?
Was that the coach team?
Yeah.
Wait, is 30 divided by 6K?
Oh, it is.
Sorry, I had to count my hands.
Well, usually we're going to watch...
It was like the finals.
But I wanted to watch earlier.
You know, just so we don't know what's going on before.
All right, so they get...
Oh, so each person gets like 6K.
That's also a lot already.
That's a lot.
510.
Oh, wait, divide by 5.
Sorry.
My math no good.
Also, English too, apparently.
I just like...
I merged like three different languages into one sentence.
My English is not good.
Oh my god, wait, there is...
What the...
They already have 16 kills?
18?
Wait, is this point control?
Okay, no, this is point control.
I was going to say...
There is no way they got 24 kills.
It's like a kill per second.
I was like, that's crazy.
Oh my god, is this gamers versus momentum?
Awesome, okay.
Guys, is the volume okay now?
Oh, I love that gun skin.
Wait, it's like...
Oh, look!
It's like he's reloading a rose.
Yeah, the fact that this is all played on mobile is actually insane.
On the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Oh my god.
Wait, that...
Wait, who's that?
There's no way.
Is that the coach?
Guys, give him the soda, baby!
Okay, he is waiting.
Wait, it's...
Jez is a coach, right?
He's gonna at least give them a bit of time to set up on the hill and maybe find...
Oh my god, he's killing everybody.
Okay, Marsh, I feel like...
Continue to ensue as both players going back and forth and Marshy showing, Hey, look, man.
I'm just as capable.
More than capable at this point.
Oh my god, they die so fast.
He's got a missile as well.
And a two-piece limit.
Marshy again popping off when he needs to.
Yeah, I'm...
Guys, the coach has 16 kills and his team...
His teammates has four.
It's literally...
It's literally coach versus coach right now.
Oh my god.
Someone stop him.
Guys, someone...
Oh my god.
Jez Nixir Reed doesn't allow you to come on through.
Who is the better kick?
The next spawns are coming on through.
Nixa running...
Oh my god.
He's still got it.
Jez right now, really helping the team.
He's a star player.
This is a very different tower point versus what we saw in our first matchup of the day, where it felt like a very even distribution.
Oh my god.
Bro, he has 20 kills.
Let me watch the other player.
All right, the time to kill is scary.
It is.
This time though, Shifty and Nixa are actually gonna be at 21.
Alan, it's already at 23.
Get on with the time.
I'm sorry.
Oh, that's so smart.
Wait, Idan is so smart.
He's like...
I'm not aiming today.
That's so funny.
That's so smart.
I'm feeling super, super confident.
Just put yourself in an awkward spot where the team, you know...
It goes that fast.
Wait, Idan.
Go, Idan.
Contribute to the kills.
We'll get them back on into the game, but it's still the gamer's lead.
Wait, this is...
Wait a minute.
This is...
This is a deathmatch.
Wait.
I just realized.
It is.
So when they were at 26, this is...
The coach literally...
It has to be, right?
The target burn.
The triple kill will help bring...
It has...
Yeah, this is...
We were like, damn, you got 26 kills.
It's hard point.
Oh, it's capture the flat.
Oh, yeah.
It's hard point.
Oh, it's hard point.
Who has the point?
Where's the point?
Oh, it isn't?
It felt like...
It felt like deathmatch with the map.
Every time they...
But they died so fast that I thought they were doing deathmatch.
Oh, that's the point.
I see the point.
They're literally like...
Oh, he's gone.
Goodbye.
My corner now.
I like the guy that killed him.
It was like...
Yoink.
I'm mine now.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Sound guy.
I know I asked you earlier if the sound was better.
And if I didn't bother reading your reply.
But I'll read your reply now.
If the sound is better now.
Who is this?
Oh, that's Shifty.
Oh!
He's able to pop green with the death machine.
Unfortunately, he can't find Jez on the point.
Yeah, I don't think he's killing Jez, guys.
I...
Oh, it's fine for now.
Nice.
He's like, can't kill...
I don't think anybody's killing Jez.
I don't think that's happening.
And my goodness.
Every single time, it looks like there's a bit of momentum going in favor of gamers.
And it's immediately Jez in particular that takes everything out of their sails.
I...
Okay, I want to know...
I want to watch deathmatch with the coaches.
I...
I think it's because, like, Marshy, his best player is picking up.
So, you see, like...
Okay, it could be because, like, Jez is just killing everybody before his teammates could kill them.
But, like, Marshy's best player, Adrian, is, like...
It's, like, almost around Marshy's, like, kill count right now.
Why I feel so slow for me?
Because we're not watching Jez.
We saw Jez play, and he was killing people every second.
And now, like, it doesn't feel the same anymore.
I...
We saw what he was doing.
And...
So, because now it feels really fast.
Because Jez is literally, like, killing every...
I mean, like, he just killed five!
Like, one!
Like, he just...
Oh, and then he gets off.
Look at that.
He got another two kills.
Jez...
Does it still feel slow, guys?
Does it still feel slow?
Whoa!
It was not just a one-man combo.
Goodness.
Oh, wait, was that Marshy?
Okay.
Wait, Marshy's catching up!
Looks like Santana, last remaining, but shifty.
That's when he's around.
Huge for gamers.
I wish...
Faster!
One, two, three...
Ba-da-da-da-da-da...
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Oh, what?
We're in Rockefeller Street.
Did you know that song isn't even...
That song isn't even written...
Was written for it...
I talked about it before...
But...
That song...
Was, like, not even written by an American.
It was done for Eurovision.
Oh my god, Marshy is caught up.
What is going... What?
What was that?
They have teleport behind you?
What?
What did I stop?
That happens, but I like the finesse.
I love the opportunity.
I love the chaos, and continuing to erupt here.
Nothing personal, kid.
Why did his teammates not help him?
Why did his teammates all just let that happen?
Nothing personal, kid.
They were expecting the 1v1.
I can't say that Momentum hasn't exactly done the same, but we're starting to see...
Um, is he right behind me, isn't he?
In order to create the gaps that we're seeing at the moment.
40 points ahead our gamers.
Momentum do have the point and are going to hold our...
Asclamation point, Samson.
They still have a very tall task ahead of them.
You shout out to Samson.
The second set of rotation for it feels like for the gamers to realize how they want to start playing this map here.
Seeing already, Adrian.
Equalizer in hand.
Oh my god, you can start fisting?
Unfortunately, there was nobody there on the point with you except the...
What was that?
What did he do?
He just, like, punched him.
You can do that?
This is a gunfight.
Oh, he's gone.
Another predator missile called on in.
He just, like, he just had his hands out and then they're dead.
Oh.
Oh, is it a cosmetic?
Call of Duty has always been, like, incredibly fast-paced.
I feel like.
Like, the TTK for Call of Duty has always been, like, this fast, especially, like, if you can headshot.
It feels like Team F right now.
I think, like...
Oh, whoa.
I think the guns are interesting.
Jez coming through, takes a couple kills of his own.
And he's not done yet.
Oh, there's...
Oh, goodbye, Jez.
And he's gonna try to stall time now for his teammates to get around.
Next up...
It's so close.
So 190, 183.
In favor of momentum.
And again...
Yeah, it's really close.
That gap growing for gamers.
It is basically erased within six points our momentum.
Huskers caught up a little bit.
Huskers actually, like, has...
He just needs to...
I think, like, the strat is that for, like, the other team.
Like, for the non-captains.
Like, their actual players.
To, like, not bump into the...
Not bump into the other coaches.
And then fight the actual players.
Oh my god.
The movement they're doing on the phone.
It's so interesting to see.
Like, like, it doesn't...
That...
It looks, like, really smooth.
This is huge for momentum to get to this point first.
Gamers within 50 now at this point.
Pass that to 200.
Yeah, they needn't...
They needn't cap the point.
They don't have point yet.
He knows he can't give this to gamers.
And let them continue on with their lead.
Pros are not...
They were built in the lab.
Um...
Excuse me.
Regular people cannot see above 60 frames per second.
Why do you need higher frames?
They can't see more than 60 frames unless you are built in the test tube.
What is going on?
Wait.
That guy tried to kill Jez standing.
I wanna...
Wait.
Who was the guy?
That was trying to kill Jez standing still.
Who was that?
Can you see that?
Oh my god.
Just stood still and he just was like, okay.
Just...
Just like...
Like...
Turns.
And then...
Who was that?
Pushing on forward.
They are here.
One last final...
I was like so confused.
I was like, did he just whip that...
Whip an entire mag?
What?
Is that an ice gun?
I don't know if you necessarily need it though.
When Marshy is popping two...
Oh wait.
There they are.
Smiles for the gamers.
You see the comms are flying.
Adrian rubbing his hands together.
Saying, hey.
I know Marshy is here.
But put some respect on my name, baby.
And I make sure...
You can...
Then you know they're all actually playing on...
On the mobile phones.
On the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Exclamation point Samsung.
Really again.
Full team effort required.
And it continues to go over the themes of the day.
As we've spoken about...
I just can't do more.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Common for both of the captains throughout this matchup.
But that's not gonna be enough.
You need to make sure...
I wonder if they have the...
Uh...
There it is.
Oh my gosh.
It's like really slim too.
I like that the phone is like slim.
I don't like bulky phones in general.
All hands baby.
All fingers.
Come on out.
I think that was like one of the big things you saw right there too.
Both Adrian and Marshy.
We're calling in predator missiles, right?
Other than the other series we watched...
It was just...
Does it take like a long time to build these missiles?
So the fact that we...
Cause like...
Jez built it like what?
Two or three times?
What sense?
Exclamation point sense.
What sense are they on?
Is it a kill streak?
Wait.
Kills...
Really?
Okay.
So...
James and Marshy both had a lot...
What is this ice...
The purifier?
What the heck is a purifier?
It's okay.
It didn't come back to punish him though.
They still take the round overall.
And not only to take the round...
They now find themselves with a 1-0 lead...
Going into our 1v1.
And as we've talked about...
This might be the most important...
It's an air appear.
Oh, it's like a flamethrower.
So...
But like for ice.
Oh!
I like how...
What's his name?
The ribby guy was like...
That's it.
I'm not aiming anymore.
Brrrr.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
He's just like...
No more aiming.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
As we get ready to go on through.
I gotta imagine...
It's only going down to like...
A one or two kill game.
It's gone.
Much different than earlier...
Where it seemed like it was like...
Five or six.
Alright, so...
They're doing next game mode.
I remember...
Wait, actually...
I think I have the format...
On what the next game mode is.
I remember they talked about it during the draft.
Should I draft?
I don't know why I put the TH there.
But I do remember that they did...
They did talk about what the...
What it is.
Let me see.
I don't remember, guys.
What was the next...
Guys, do you guys remember the next game mode?
Bang, bang, bang.
Over and over again.
And I wonder if that ability to have those quick reactions...
And those individual guns...
It's an ice cosmetic for the pure...
Nope, guys.
You were supposed to be my brains.
You ain't got this, brother.
You guys streamers don't think?
I do remember that it would be played on the Samsung Galaxy S25.
You know what?
That's a good thing to remember, though.
I'm glad...
I'm glad you met you.
That's actually a good thing to remember.
Is it for $15,000 though?
I want you to know which game mode goes next.
Wrong streamer.
Wait, it's 1v1?
Oh, is it coach versus coach?
Oh, it's 1v1.
On Kill House.
Because this is a strong opportunity right now, like you said.
Where you lose that hard point.
Definitely a lot closer than I think we would have imagined.
It was just off of some, you know, final sort of good smart plays.
And kills that transition to hill time.
From the gamers that give them that map.
But when it comes on down to the series as a whole.
I feel like Jess definitely really has an opportunity to come right on back.
Tie up this series and say, yo, we're at least going to another hard point.
Right?
We're at least being able to...
1v1.
Final destination.
Coaches only.
Haha.
If Marshy is able to win this.
Put them up 2-0.
And then we got to go into that express search and destroy.
In map number 3.
But I mean...
Search and destroy?
Which one is search?
Wait, is search and destroy like...
Um...
It's like tactical shooter, right?
Is that search and destroy?
Yeah.
I was gonna say...
Oh, they can't...
You're not allowed to look at each other.
Haha.
You see like the little...
The boxed up area?
You're not allowed to look at each other.
Haha.
But it's not going to be easy.
Doing anything you can to avoid that scenario...
Oh my...
Haha.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is...
Ohhhh.
He had the initial shots, but...
Airborne is Marshy to get...
Wait, I wanna...
Oh, yeah.
This is coach versus coach.
Ohhhh.
That was a nice shot.
It's like whoever hits that headshot.
Jesus!
Oh what?
That was one hit!
What did he do?!
Does he have a sniper?
Oh, it's a sniper.
Oh, now he has a shotgun.
Oh, wait, this is... Is this gun game?
Oh, it's loadout.
That's his loadout.
He has a sniper shotgun.
Oh, that's crazy.
No, he's literally running sniper shotgun.
That is so... That... That is... Oh, my God.
That's the overcomp.
Okay, this is actually... Jesus!
Why is she?
Oh, he can't get ladders!
That is an insane shot.
Like, one shot sniper?
Like, the confidence in that.
That's scary.
If he's, like, a really good sniper, like, it's so hard to, like...
Jesus!
That was a body shot.
Unlucky.
Wait, I want to see him use it...
What's the loaded glitch?
The KRM-262.
Is that, like... Is that a shotgun or a sniper?
Is that a sniper?
With only one kill.
The... The one that Marshy's holding on?
Try and take a look.
It is all mobile.
What's so crazy about these shotguns?
You show yourself for just even a split second and you are getting cut on.
Jeez.
Oh, this is a shotgun v.
Shotgun now.
Six to six right now.
We knew this was gonna be close.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
They're just running... What?
Wait, so headshot shotgun is insta-kill.
Oh, my... Okay.
That's... That's scary.
That's actually... That's actually scary.
No, they're all just playing on their... The Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
What is that shot?
I'm not gonna even do this in FNK.
That's... Like, the strafing is actually so good.
I actually... It's always, like, so impressive to watch, like, really good players strafe.
With him.
It's not gonna be enough for Marshy to win that one.
And Jez will take another...
I like normal blood, but high cali- Calibre.
That's not a shotgun.
That's a cannon.
Maybe two kills.
And at that, it's...
I like how he...
Like, wait, it's...
Oh, my God.
The ladder juke.
We keep going, though.
Again.
Oh, wow.
You're almost at the halfway mark.
Okay, that was really good.
That was a good shot.
Yeah.
What the...
It's like the mind game.
What?
What was that shot?
I want rewind.
I want, like...
I want the rewind of that.
Bro, this should be a montage.
They should put...
They put this in a montage.
These are some insane shots.
Like, look at that movement.
Demon, he didn't lose momentum.
Like, he...
Do you see how he's, like, the...
The 360 rotate?
He literally didn't lose momentum from that.
Like...
It's so...
Where?
I can't burn.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I want to see, like, replay.
Like, some of these shots are insane.
I feel like we've got a half a second just to stay here.
Like, you can only peek for, like, one second.
Doesn't matter the distance.
Shotguns will fire.
Marshy will try to escape.
Running all the way back, knowing that if he gets stabbed even once more, that's another kill for Jez, and we get closer to a tie game.
That's crazy.
This movement is, like, so fun to watch.
That's a God 1v1 right there.
Yeah, the one frame peek.
Yeah, he has to, like, figure out where he is.
Oh, and then there's, like, regen, so he's waiting for it.
Oh!
Okay.
That was the overconfidence of that.
Keep believing that Marshy is going to find himself a bit of a lead, and it will not be fouled.
The furthest he can get away from Jez at this point is maybe two kills, and maybe doing a lot of heavy lifting in that sentence as we...
Oh, my God.
...go back to a tie game.
It's tied.
This is so close.
This is actually incredibly close.
These 1v1s are so fun to watch.
Yeah.
High-level gaming has always been, like, incredible.
It's just very impressive that this is all done on...
These are, like, mobile pro players, so they're obviously very used to the mechanics of playing on mobile, but it is incredibly impressive, and it's, like, really interesting to see, like, what you can do in mobile gaming.
There's a semblance of a lead here.
If you can find another third one...
And, like, it's all done on, like, the Samsung Galaxy.
That's 25 Ultra.
Again, we just can't seem to escape that two-kill margin.
And they're streaming this, too.
The fact that it's, like...
They're streaming this gameplay...
Um...
Oh, my God.
...he's gonna increase it further.
17 for Jez.
Three away.
Jez is winning this?
I don't...
Oh, wait, Jez.
Oh, my God.
Wait, he is.
Oh, what?
He wall-banged her.
Wait.
Wait, Jez wall-b...
What?
Okay, that was impressive.
Almost closed this one on out.
Only two more needed.
That's insane.
The wall-bang?
Two fantastic players.
Jez, a lot of pressure on your shoulders.
Jez, no, Jez.
Oh, the movement.
Jez, turn around.
Turn around.
No, he didn't.
Oh, no.
Jez needs him.
Jez is...
Oh!
Last kill.
I think Jez is mechanically is the better player.
Oh!
That was a good match to watch.
That was...
Oh, he has to...
Oh, he has...
You know, he's a professional.
You see that?
He has to...
You know, okay, so, like, for those who don't know, and, um...
For those who don't know, in, um...
Uh, PC, people have...
Wear, like, the arm sleeve.
But on mobile gaming, they wear, like, these, like, the finger sleeves.
Yeah.
The...
I don't know what they're called.
The thumb...
The thumb sleeves.
Jez and Marshy...
Because it makes the movement...
Because, like, um...
For those who don't know, it's because, like...
Okay, so, like, for the people...
The reason why people wear arm sleeve is because, um...
The texture of your skin and also, like, the hair, like, for...
Especially for guys, the hair on your arms produces friction and also, like, there's sweat and stuff.
So...
Because, you know, you're sweating and stuff.
It makes your movement a lot less smooth and a lot less, like...
It's more slow and rough when you're moving your arm.
So that's why you see pro players wear, like, arm sleeves.
For mobile gamers, they wear thumb sleeves.
So...
I don't know what the proper term is, but I've...
I've heard of them.
It does the same thing because, like, it reduces the texture on your thumbs and also, like, it doesn't have, like, you know, it absorbs the sweat.
So...
So you can have, like, a smoother...
A smoother, like, aim and stuff.
So...
Yeah!
I'm a nerd!
I hope one day I get an arm sneeze sponsor.
And finger sneeze.
I will make sure that I'll have finger sneeze for the mobile gamers, too.
I'm inclusive for all.
I've already seen mobile gaming in the next few years.
I think mobile gaming is just going to get more and more popular because, like, it's already incredibly popular in Asia in general.
Like, there's a lot of, like, there's, like, you know, a lot of, like, MOBAs, FPS.
I know, like, there's a lot of MOBAs and FPS games in...
for eSports and mobile for...
in Asia and Southeast Asia in general.
So it's already incredibly popular.
For those who don't know, in the...
in the eSport World Cup, if you guys didn't know, if you guys see in the eSport World Cup, the stuff that's in there, there's actually a lot of...
a lot of...
Sorry, I need to turn it down because I get this...
my brain doesn't work so well when I'm...
when I'm listening to them talking as a whole while.
You know, like, when someone else is talking?
Um, when someone else is talking and then you, you, like, absorb what they're saying into your head and then, like, it, like, messes with your sentences and stuff?
Uh, uh, uh, like, that's what's going on in my head right now.
Anyway, as I was saying, uh, let me turn them down.
Dude, my stuff is more important right now.
Wait, actually...
Okay, I already analyzed their gameplay.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway, so, for those who don't know, um, for those...
Okay, they're analyzing their gameplay right now, guys.
They're analyzing the gameplay.
But I want to give an interesting fact.
For those who don't know, um, in the Overwatch...
Not Overwatch, sorry.
In the, uh, World...
Cup...
World Cup eSports.
Um, that's going to be, like, happening in a couple of months.
They actually included, I think, like, two to three mobile games in the eSports World Cup.
Um, because they're in...
And I was, like, looking at it, and I was like, what games are these?
I don't...
like, I've never heard about these games before.
I looked them up, um, because there's, like, a lot of big game titles in the eSports World Cup.
And you know, there's a lot of money being invested in it, too.
And, um, and I looked them up and they're all, like, really popular titles within, like, Asia and Southeast Asia that's just for, like, mobile gaming.
And you have, like, you have to know, like, to even be, like, considered in the eSports World Cup, they have to have a lot of money invested in it.
Because, like, first place in the eSports World Cup is, like, like, millions of dollars in general.
Like, I think it's, like, I remember, like, some of the game prizes, like, game prizes for it, for the, because it's literally the eSports World Cup.
Like, it's, the entire world is participating, um, in that, in there for various game titles.
Uh, so, some of the, some of the games, some of the, um, some of the games that's involved, the prizes are, like, millions of dollars in general.
And to even be involved in it, and to be, like, a team in the eSports World Cup, they have, it's, like, you have to, you know, be able to invest in it and be able, like, basically pay to be in the tournament and stuff like that.
So, the fact that they had, like, two to three mobile games in there, just to be part of the The eSport World Cup is already like... you know how much money was already invested into it... in general.
So that's like a little insider... I know like actual insider knowledge of how much money was spent.
But also I don't know, even teams have to pay to be involved in the eSport World Cup.
So like... and I know how much teams have to pay to be like in it.
Because it's like, you know, you're buying in a spot.
It's not like... it's not a... it's not like, you know, a league of it.
They have to buy a spot to be able to participate.
So that's why you can see a lot of teams signing up like...
So like, for example, you can see like teams and various other game titles...
signing up, like rapidly signing teams up right now...
to be part of the eSport World Cup.
Yeah, you're not ready for that player to be kind of waiting on in there...
So like, you know how like there's some titles where like, you know, they never had a team before...
But when they announced that a particular game...
is in...
um...
a particular game is like in the eSport World Cup...
They quickly like...
Even the last like two to three weeks, there were so many teams...
that got announced...
signed...
to like an org...
because they want to bring a team to participate in the World Cup...
since they already bought a spot...
to participate in it.
that momentum...
Yeah, did keep their momentum...
from the 1v1...
Yeah...
Jez...
What on earth, brother?
Just taking a...
But yeah, it's quite interesting...
Like it's an interest...
I like like learning about stuff like that...
I guess it's just...
Oh, this is the...
Search and Destroy, right?
That's what happens...
You're...
You're getting put on...
It's one-to-one now...
Like the...
I love the gun skins...
They're so interesting...
I'm seeing some early picks go on through...
But we...
Get down into this round...
Into a 2v2 right now...
And gamers...
They're kind of starting to work this together...
Santana...
He's kind of making a big rap on the outside...
Trying to clear it...
But you're leaving your teammate all alone...
I'm so bad at these types of game modes...
I'm not patient enough...
Especially when the time to kill is so fast...
But you just have to...
Wait, who's planting?
Okay...
Blue is defender...
Wait...
Oh...
They don't wanna...
They can't...
They have to rush him...
No!
Why did you help him?
Oh my god!
Marshy baited his team!
Marshy was like...
Marshy's like...
You're not the better player...
You go do it for me...
Marshy actually...
Whatever it takes...
He's like...
You know you're not better than me...
Whatever it takes...
I'll try and win this 1v1...
Cause even if Marshy loses that...
Opportunity...
For obviously...
Being able to...
To maybe just have it go just long enough...
That there's not gonna be an opportunity for that bomb...
It must be done...
Also that's why I don't like...
I don't like...
Like...
These...
Tactical shooter type gameplay...
Because...
For me...
It's more like...
Haha...
You get baited so hard...
But...
He...
Either I bait the team...
My teammates...
Or they bait me...
And that pisses me off...
Haha...
Wait...
Where was he aiming at?
Haha...
He's like...
Who is he?
Which has now left them in a 2v1...
Technically to their advantage...
I'm gonna blow my nose guys...
And I'm not muting...
Cause I'm lazy...
Yeah...
I don't have enough mind for these games!
You see Jez...
Just...
Push on down there...
Looking at the bottom ramp...
We'll catch that player...
Pushing on out...
So...
But yeah...
I...
Oh yeah...
But yeah...
Like...
Um...
An example would be like...
You know how like...
Um...
Apex signed a lot of teams...
Recently...
Like...
Apex Orgs...
Signed a bunch of teams...
Because a lot of them...
Have spots in the World Cup...
And...
Another way to get into...
Like...
Not just like...
For like...
All game titles...
Either a team...
Buys in a spot...
For the World Cup...
Or...
Um...
This is for all the game titles...
Or...
They have enough...
Points...
In the league...
So like...
If you're...
If you don't have...
If you're not...
Um...
If you're not one of the teams...
That have a guaranteed spot...
In the World Cup...
Um...
It's all dependent...
On like...
How many points you get...
From the league...
Of...
From like...
Um...
The reason why...
You don't see like...
Marvel Rivals...
In the World Cup...
Is...
Because...
Uh...
They don't have a league yet...
Um...
The MRC doesn't count as a league...
In Marvel Rivals...
He's not only gotten a kill through the box...
He gets two players...
In one round...
It's just they haven't started a league...
Cause...
MRC is like...
Anyone can enter...
It's not like...
A...
Um...
It's not like...
Actual like...
League...
Where like...
All the top teams...
Are like...
Automatically in...
Organization though...
Again...
Momentum...
Quick to the point...
Quick to the kills...
Already three dead...
Four gamers...
Just because they have no opportunity...
To...
Yeah...
It has to be more exclusive...
Fights...
And really kind of...
Push it into their favor...
It's just...
You're losing all your gunfights...
Immediately into a round...
And...
You're constantly putting your teammates...
In these 2v3...
2v4 situations...
It's Marshy and Shifty...
Last two members alive...
Cause there's no LAN event...
That's the thing...
If there's no LAN event...
It doesn't count...
Cause the MRC is all online...
And also the MRI...
Task here...
But there's like...
All the other game titles...
That you see in the World Cup...
They're all like LAN events...
You can spread a lot of space...
Right now here...
Cut some of these players off...
And I like this...
Play 2x2...
Get some of this info...
If you need it...
Fight on the outside...
It's Marshy...
He gets some of the...
Immediate shots...
On to Huskers...
Cuts them on down...
We'll go ahead...
Back on up...
He's trying to be able to...
Take this fight...
Your teammates on the other side...
You have a real opportunity...
To sandwich this bomb site...
To try and come alive...
And Marshy...
Oh...
Somehow does not die...
To those first initial shots...
Wait...
Where's the...
Where's the bomb?
Oh...
Oh my god...
Yeah...
Oh...
It's...
It's literally...
They just need...
Jez to be alive...
Like...
I feel...
This is so...
Defender sided...
I feel like this is...
Like this map is...
Defender sided...
He's alive...
And already defusing the bomb...
He gets the kill...
Immediately...
What?
Wait...
Jez...
What?
The...
Wampang prediction...
Really using strategic approach in this game...
Combined with...
Just straight up being able to kill anybody...
Within the blink of an eye...
And you can see right now...
On to the offense...
The gamer...
That was so cool...
We actually got killed there...
Haha...
Marshy...
Want to get this early contact...
Get this early...
Don't get...
Oh...
Marshy...
You can't die...
Why did the Swiss...
And...
Marshy...
If just like that...
Blink of an eye...
It was a full setup...
Trying to get bombed out...
It's just you...
Trying...
Bro, he's one HP...
I don't think he's gonna kill Jez...
Yeah...
What?
Just not gonna be enough...
Five...
Two...
From momentum...
I...
I just think this is very...
Defense sided...
I think if they are...
The gas...
They are...
I mean...
Those very attack side...
Yeah...
They are trying to take this map...
And get us that arsenal hard point...
And I do think the word they...
Is gonna be the biggest thing here...
It is a full team effort right now...
Yes Jez...
With almost 20...
They swapped, right?
But if you look at the other side...
For our attackers right now...
In gamers...
It has not been a full team effort here...
Finally...
We do see a couple of eliminations...
Across the board there...
As I think...
Actually it might...
I don't know...
It feels like...
I feel like this is very defense side...
In general...
In our prior...
Just cause like...
A combination of...
Now eight...
As they do pick up another...
Just cause it seems...
Very easy to...
Spread across the board...
To kill the attackers...
Man...
He's popping off when he needs to...
Finding himself eight kills of his own...
So...
Again...
Right now...
Momentum...
Playing well as a team...
Even though...
Oh my god...
Go!
Guys...
I think it's over...
Jess is alive...
And Marshy isn't...
Oh no...
The poor...
Poor little guy...
It's so...
It's so over...
The moment I saw...
That Marshy was dead...
I knew it was over...
I...
What if...
Kill Search is...
I like how Kill Search is like...
What if Clutch?
And then we're in the next round...
I...
It's a little too late for that...
It's...
We're...
Really...
This was...
This...
Jez is literally just baiting his entire team...
Like...
That's...
That's all he...
He's just been...
He's literally baiting his entire team...
Why can't Marshy do that?
SACRIFICE MARSHI, NOOOOO!
That was good, this team played really well there.
I think Marshy's team isn't playing together right now.
They're literally always... they're like so split for attack.
Does it have a highlight reel or is it just watching Jez back, basically?
Even they're like, is it just Jez?
Even the capster is like...
I told you!
All they have to do is fake your teammates and search and destroy!
Just fake your teammates!
Maybe!
Oops, all Jez!
Just Jez!
Jesus, that was such an insane shot.
Look, there's Marshy though!
It's not just Jez!
I like how they're not including Jez in this highlight!
They're like...
They're trying so hard to only include one clip of Jez!
Oh, nevermind!
Oh, there's another Jez clip!
Oh, there he is!
And then they came up there!
Jez has his own highlight!
I'm surprised there's even clips that aren't Jez!
Oh, there he is again!
Nevermind!
It was on...
It was like five clips of Jez and then one...
And then like two from Marshy and then like...
The lucky two people get their own clip!
He is exactly where he was going to be!
He nails it perfectly!
And not only does he do that, but he continues on with the unbelievable streak he has had!
I think he dropped 50 in our first match!
True, it should have been hard!
And then he does, I think, either 20 or 30 again!
He is on track!
Actually, no!
I think he's already passed the 100 points!
Jez put this entire tournament in his highlight reel!
This should be his highlight reel right now!
Take his thumb sleeves!
He's too good!
Make it more even!
Give him the friction!
Until basically that...
It's not fair!
Yes!
It was neck and neck all the way through!
Just a couple of those moments where basically they get some crucial kills!
That doesn't allow momentum to get in on the point!
And get in any of that time!
Not the friction!
Make him sweat on his Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra!
Make him sweat on it!
They're coming in with a lot of momentum!
It's okay, they're built to be durable!
He's trying to take this map four!
Win it in a 3-1 to make it to our grand final!
I kind of feel so...
His thumbs will get shy!
Check his...
Check his fingers!
They are...
Yeah, they are water resistant guys!
They are water resistant!
It kind of felt like...
Is he using prosthetics?
Enhanced...
Prosthetics in hands of thumbplay?
Okay?
What is he hiding underneath the thumb's knees?
Does he have aimbot underneath his thumbs?
He was actually playing with like two, four thumbs.
I feel like you have... I feel like... do you have to be like sort of ambidextrous...
a little bit ambidextrous to be really good at mobile gaming?
Because yeah, I guess like hand-eye coordination in general.
But I feel like with mobile gaming, you definitely have to have more coordination versus just M&K.
Pay no attention to that.
If you take off the sleeve, it's just like a tinier person.
It's like... it's like a mini person with like...
like little hands and legs underneath.
And it was being able to find those kills, convert it into hill time, and be able to take that map.
But we are getting right...
Yeah, you can't really... you can't really depend on one hand more.
I feel like you have to have both... both your hands have to be like really...
like coordinated for mobile.
Around the world, I mean right here on the desk in this camera...
are very excited to hop on into Arsenal.
Let's get ready.
It is map number four.
Memento!
You're going for a map four.
This isn't a... this is actually a lot closer.
Snug, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Not only a good shot at doing that, but I think that it's going to be very telling how we start this map.
I know we've talked a lot about that today.
About, you know, putting your best foot forward and starting off in a sprint, not a jog.
But I do think it's going to be even more important here.
Considering the fact that they have taken the momentum from the last two maps, have played really well through the last two, whether individually for Jez or the entire team that has played well as a collective...
What are their team's names?
Why is it just Jez?
Jez plus friends.
So for gamers here, do not let momentum get an early start, or you will have an early end to your tournament.
Definitely got to keep it alive.
That is for certain.
Arsenal is going to be a very fun map to go ahead and dive on into.
I believe five points on this map.
Jez and et al.
We are about ready.
We are moments away from being able to hop on in.
We just got to go ahead and resolve a quick little issue, and then we will be jumping on in.
So you got to deal with us just for one more hot little second as we get ready to hop on in.
Let's talk about some of the maps in this series, because we kicked it off.
Yeah, what's the next one?
With this summit hardpoint.
And as we get ready to move on into the arsenal...
Oh, they get to pick the map?
On your screen.
We kind of mentioned a lot of that, right?
Yeah.
And then we have, of course, that kill house with the 1v1...
Jez and friends.
...that we watched, of course.
Jez really finally...
It came down to the wire all the way at the end, but if I was able to really run away with it.
And that was where we felt like momentum started getting the pendulum back into their corner as we then headed on into that express with a 7-2 victory.
So if you are gamers right now, obviously, you are trying to take this arsenal.
You're trying to push us all the way to a map number five, being Tunisia, which is a Call of Duty mobile original.
So really only...
It's just real.
You're just living in it.
You know, caster bias is not a thing I want to lean too far into, but gamers, I will do anything.
I feel like that 1v1 that Marshy had with Jez, like...
It, like, demoralized him.
Because he got...
He started playing incredibly aggressive after that 1v1.
Like, he tried to, like, basically play like a hero.
Like, he's like, I'm going to kill everybody.
And then Jez was like, I'm going to let everyone else die, and then I'll kill everybody.
What kind of processor does the Samsung Galaxy have?
Oh, good question.
It has...
Okay, it uses a Snapdragon 8 Elite.
So apparently that's, like, the most advanced processor on the Galaxy phone.
A Snapdragon 8 Elite.
Yeah.
So you get fast...
I mean, we've already seen the...
The fast performance and smooth gameplay.
It looks so smooth on...
On this...
On this stream.
Like, it's so...
You can't...
It just looks incredible.
The graphics looks really good.
And the movement too!
The fact that I played at 120 frames for this?
At least $1,000.
Loser.
Not walking home empty-handed.
17,500 for them.
So definitely still would love to be able to get to that grand final to secure that cash.
But it's not the only opportunity to earn some money today, because our two teams that do make it to our grand final...
They're actually...
Their captains are...
But can it run, Crysis?
What?
But...
I bet it can, honestly.
Yeah, it's made to handle Unreal Engine 5.
At this point, probably.
Okay, that's the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra!
Exclamation point, Samsung!
Thank you again, Samsung!
For these players to play for.
And that is why we...
I mean, it is.
Like, 6k per player?
That's like...
That's rent money.
That's money they...
Oh, and they're in Las Vegas!
They need that 6k for Las Vegas!
I just realized.
That 7-2 was one map off of instead of us having the day...
Vegas, baby!
Teams are added...
I mean, every team gets money, though.
So it's third and fourth place.
Third and fourth place gets money as well.
Turn potential rent money in.
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha!
Viva Las Vegas!
They get to watch...
Wait, isn't there like...
Wait, is...
What's her name?
Um...
Isn't Mariah Carey in Las Vegas?
Performing...
Oh, it's...
I don't know.
Wait, wasn't Britney Spears in Las Vegas?
Who's performing in Las Vegas right now?
They always have, like, one star, like, one celebrity in Las Vegas that's doing, like, performances there for, like, a year or something.
I don't know.
I might not be, like, hip with the times right now.
They get to see... Oh my god!
They get to see Magicians!
Magic!
And whoever won America's Got Talent!
Sounder, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Okay, they always...
In the, like, America's Got Talent, it's always, like, one of the first-place prize...
Mind free!
The first-place prize is always, like, a year tour in Las Vegas or something.
The best of their ability.
Enough of us yapping, I'm being told.
Arsenal Hardpoint is ready to go.
So, of course, we are looking at the gamers.
This is do or die for them.
And they need to clutch this one on up to bring...
Okay, you still win 17.5k, though.
How much did I get per player, guys?
Human calculator!
Calculate for me!
17.5k divided by five.
I'm waiting.
And I think the wait is over.
Let's get it started!
As you mentioned, do or die for...
No!
A lot!
Guys, please!
I can't math!
I refuse!
What if you guys don't have free will?
All I need is one!
Oh my god!
They instantly killed four people!
No help!
Fergo dies.
When the 2 comes on through, right?
So, you're already see some early eliminations...
No problem is the favor.
Nice nade!
We'll kick-start you there, as it is just...
Okay, one point...
Guys!
There's so many different numbers that I actually don't know what's right.
All right, guys!
What is...
What is 17.5k divided by five?
Too much math.
Guys, bring out your Samsung Galaxy X25 Ultra phones and calculate for me.
Between 3 and 4.
3.5k?
I knew it.
I knew one of you guys.
I knew a few of you will break.
That's still a lot.
3.5k?
That's actual show money.
You can see magic.
Oh, this is Team Deathmatch.
Jez, please.
Oh.
Jez has teammates that... Marshy has teammates that are picking up the kills, but Jez doesn't.
Jez is a one-man show.
Jesus.
Bro, they're using... Okay, Jez... Marshy's team is actually using util.
I think Marshy's team is better at using util.
Bro, 35 to 18?
Oh my god!
Oh.
Yeah.
Yeah, Marshy's team is more playing as a team versus Jez's team.
That's not going to be enough.
That's not good.
Marshy's team might have better individual players.
Oh, is it hardpoint?
Oh, it's hardpoint again?
I was like, Jesus.
56 to 18?
There's so many.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, they did.
Marshy's team did win last.
Okay, then it'll be 2-2.
What's after hardpoint again?
Yeah, Jez can't...
I think Jez is not good at...
Jez's team right is not good at hardpoint.
Keeping it contestant right now from...
Uh, Marshy's team knows how to...
Marshy's team knows how to, um...
Defend better.
It's going in up over the front, but that's three dead in the feed on the side of momentum.
Jez, please!
Okay, this is like a little embarrassing, Jez.
I'm trying to be able to make sure...
That your team can get back on into this...
Jez, how can this...
Jez, you can't put this in your highlight reel if you got knocked out.
If you get third and fourth place.
It kind of feels like right now, we are seeing gamers, as it looks like Marshy now gonna...
I love it when they use the...
When they use the grenade launcher, they're just like...
They're just like, whatever.
I don't want to aim anymore.
What is he?
What is Shifty?
Shifty, are you?
Sorry.
Shifty's...
This is what happens when you don't wear your thumb's knees.
Oh, what if like...
That's why he didn't wear his thumb's knees.
And then like...
You know how...
Are you playing along?
Like in like the water?
Like, you know, he sweat...
Maybe he sweats a lot?
And then like the sweat like was touching the...
The movement key a bit too long?
Yeah, he got bit of the sweat on the screen.
He's trying to hopefully catch somebody on that ladder hop-up.
That's what I thought.
I was like...
Jez, are you okay?
Aiden, surges on forward.
We'll get that first blood.
Already three dead in the feed.
Four gamers momentum will answer on back.
Here's kind of my worry bass.
Is that, you know, momentum.
They're doing a great job.
They break these hills.
They get on top of the point.
But it's with 10 seconds left.
You need to already be thinking about the next...
Oh.
Oh, is it going to rotate to the next point?
Yeah, if you look at the mini map.
Like, Marshy's team is like so much more coordinated when it comes to like hard points.
Towards this point.
Where's the next point?
No.
A huge win.
Oh my god.
They already killed everybody.
They were set up on that rotation to cut everyone down.
But the gamers win a crucial gunfight.
They get on the end of this point.
And it is just all shots going their way.
As they've now crawled to a 60 point lead.
This is a complete clip of the script of what we saw before.
We talked about this in S&D of where it really was.
Everybody on momentum carrying their weight.
Individual players all finding themselves a decent amount of kills and a decent amount of strategery.
That is not happening anymore.
It is gamers instead who are doing that with almost every single player on the team.
Jesus.
At least 10 kills.
The util for Marshy's team is so good.
Because they keep their...
They keep their...
Look, look, look.
It's literally one guy defending...
Defending the point and stealth.
Yeah, their team play is really good.
They have really good coordination.
They're definitely like talking.
Calming a lot.
We'll get caught on down.
But thankfully the rest of the team...
Yeah, this is a little...
Just...
This is a little embarrassing.
Um...
We might not have...
You can't upload a highlight reel.
You get four plays.
It's like everybody is contributing.
What the...
How did he get three kills?
Wait, Marshy.
How did you...
Marshy just got like four kills.
What happened?
What did he do?
Michi, I think about two gifted subs.
Thank you.
Yeah, we didn't see what he did.
I was curious.
Oh, wait.
They got the point though.
They have to rush it.
Oh.
They have to kill Jez.
They can kill Jez and then like just walk in.
I think if all of them just rushed him, I think it'd be fine.
Oh, there you go.
Jez down.
Go in.
Go, go, go.
Wait.
Literally.
Oh, wait.
It literally was that.
They're like...
They just have to kill Jez.
Jez down.
Go, go, go.
Raid boss down.
Charge.
You have to have your timing.
Be a little bit better.
P2 will come online.
It's close.
Oh, they got it back though.
They get it back?
Yeah, they got it back.
They have to go to the new point.
Do you manage to find...
Get him!
Marshi, no!
Rush him!
Jez down!
The plan.
Go, Jez.
Wait, Jez's teammate.
Oh my God, that guy.
Wait.
Did he see he...
He dated himself.
That's a doki move right there.
Yeah, he missed the nade.
Guys, that's a doki move right there.
Yeah.
That's me.
I would do that.
Jez is literally just fighting on point.
He does not care.
Oh yeah, that's a doki move.
Wait, they're catching up.
I think they really...
I think Jez finally realized that he needs a team.
Or he just locked in more.
I can't tell.
I can't tell if he's just more locked in or he's playing with his team.
When they need to.
We talked about Hustlers, Nathan, Santana, Noemi.
Having to make sure they get those shrink of kills when they are available.
It's what allows the team to get the numbers advantage.
Yeah, this is a Call of Duty mobile tournament.
Hosted by...
Presented by Samsung.
Or the Samsung Galaxy.
S25 Ultra.
Exclamation point, Samsung!
I don't think they should play patiently.
They just literally need to rush Jez.
They're playing way too patient for like...
The actual gameplay that they have to do.
He was going off the kill feed with that.
But he gets stopped very, very quickly.
You see Marshy just trying to hold this hunt.
Oh, no!
He's won!
Get him!
Oh, my God.
Marshy should not have held that himself.
It's okay.
I think he's coming back now.
I did it!
Stop it again!
I did!
I don't...
He just dated himself.
That's a little embarrassing, bro.
That's a little embarrassing.
I think...
Is there friendly fire?
With nades?
Guys, is there friendly fire?
It's not bad.
If there is, he actually killed...
Oh, no.
Thank God.
Okay.
Wouldn't it be funny if he killed his team there?
Down.
And that's what we're seeing here.
We warned about it coming into the map.
That you cannot allow these leads to grow too large.
Because if you do, the comeback is just going to be...
Oh.
Oh, that's a little embarrassing.
I feel like...
I feel...
Oh my God.
I feel like you should be able to.
Oh, it's...
The lead's too big again.
If they even find a handful more of points, it will be difficult for momentum to ever stifle them again.
Oh, you can even see on the top of your screen.
Where's the point?
Oh, it's over there.
Oh, that was a good shot from Huskers.
Jesus.
55 to 40 versus 49.
The second best...
Jez's second best teammate has 17 kills.
For now, they are going to go ahead and sit into that point.
They'll be 20 points away from taking this map.
Oh, a new point.
New point.
I still think...
Marshy has better...
Has better teammates.
Wait, actually?
No, Huskers with 22 kills.
It's hard to tell, actually.
Whoa!
Oh, he has a killstreak.
Oh!
That was good.
That was really good.
Do you find a fourth?
You might be able to, but Marshy...
Oh, it didn't matter.
His teammates died.
And he got four kills.
And his teammates still died.
This is how you crash out.
This is when...
This is when you don't pick off of vibes, guys.
This is...
Oh, baby.
Maybe a triple.
Is...
This is GG.
Oh, it's two to two, though.
It's two to two.
Just learns today.
You never pick off of vibes.
Three more points.
Make it two.
Make it not one.
Somehow momentum.
Hold them off.
And with only a two-point gap remaining, they're still in this thing.
They need the...
They just need...
Oh!
You're looking at this.
Oh, no.
140 points.
Wait, they're coming over.
What was that?
Try and come back on in.
It's still not...
Oh, they got it.
They got the point.
With Marshy going in...
Marshy got another point.
He's trying to gas him up, and he's just locked on in.
He's like, wait, let me get a screenshot of this real quick.
This is going to go in the timeline.
Let me go ahead.
Let me snag that on him.
You can see Adrian hyped, bringing the energy shifty.
I know he's electric right now.
Freeboy and Nyksta.
They have to come to that map as well to come online.
Feeling good.
Looks like the team is happy.
The comms are there.
Is that Marshy?
With the finger sleeves?
It has to be Marshy, right?
We were on search and destroy.
I assume the...
You look great for your team.
Yeah, and I think that's why Marshy's not taking too much time to celebrate here.
He knows that, yeah, we might have been able to win the hard...
Oh, he's the one that's like...
Wait!
I like his...
That they're like, yeah, Marshy's not celebrating just yet.
Like, he's the only one that didn't even look up from his phone, because he was like, it's not over.
It's...
He was like...
Then this rest of the team was like, yay!
Yippee!
And then Marshy's just like, it's not over.
It's not over.
Arsenal hardpoint definitely did not disappoint.
Yeah, he's locked in.
Like, they're on, like, Marshy's backpack right now.
It's like, yippee!
We did it!
Huge plays.
Predator missile double kill into a solid one.
But, yeah, this ending from Marshy was absolutely insane.
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
Guys, I'll be back.
The war machine going crazy.
It's the killstreaks going crazy.
It's everything.
Notice, Marshy didn't even fist bump.
She was like, come on, guys!
We did it!
Fist bump!
And Marshy didn't even look up to say, good job.
All the way to a game number five in the second.
It's really the best of both worlds.
Hey, are you not entertained?
It's the only thing I can ask at this point here.
And I also have an ask of our production team.
I need somebody on the background.
I know graphics is probably already doing way too many things.
But if you can find a way to figure out how many kills we've got, Jez versus Marshy right now.
Dude, I think both of them are at least at triple digits at this point.
So, let's find out.
Can they break through those three digits and get to four?
I don't think so, but we can determine a winner.
Our fifth and final game here.
The winner of this will move on to the grand final here for the Samsung Galaxy Gear Up Cup.
And will guarantee themselves at least a 1v1 battle for $15,000 for the captain.
If that isn't enough encouragement, I don't know what is.
Yeah.
Lock in, friends, because this is absolutely electric that we have coming on in Tunisia.
A Call of Duty Mobile Original.
I do kind of wonder when we think back to Express.
A lot of our players, they might have some sort of reps just from back in the day.
I'm back.
They've played the map before.
They know how it looks and plays.
But for some of these players, they might be loading into Tunisia for the very first time.
They might have no idea how this map plays.
I don't move around.
So, I'm going to look at our captains to start distilling some of that information of where to look.
Where do we want to play?
Where do we want to hang out?
Wait, what did they say was next?
Game mode.
Guys, you guys hear what they said it was?
Very early on.
I hope you at least load it up into a custom game on Tunisia to be able to at least get a feel for the map.
Be able to see what's there.
How do you want to hold on in?
Not yet?
Okay.
Let's get it started, folks.
We are hopping right on in.
Search and destroy.
Oh.
Bro, that's why Marshy was so locked in.
Marshy was like, no.
Oh, boy.
It was a two-to-two.
And then all of a sudden...
Marshy just beat your teammates.
And things started to turn.
Momentum.
Marshy is scared.
With all the momentum in the world in their favor.
Oh, they got first.
Oh, the provide.
Jazz's team got first kill.
Yep.
That's why.
What?
Okay.
So, at least, like...
From the gamers, two members do get found out from...
Oh, Marshy did get two.
You might have a timing here.
Adrian, you might have an opportunity.
Drop some down.
Drop some there.
But you're not able to finish the kill.
Oh!
No, no.
It's just...
Okay.
Oh, Jazz is one HP.
Wait.
He's getting healed.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Is there, like...
There's regen, right?
Oh, my God.
He's just regen-ing.
But he has 47 seconds.
What?
What was that?
He was, like...
You could tell he got scared.
Oh, they dropped bomb.
30 seconds.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was good.
That was a good guard.
That was good, actually.
This chat was good.
I thought that we might be seeing the 2v1 go completely against them with the maneuvers.
Jez was so fast, though.
Like, he was zooming.
Yeah, that teamwork was really good.
Because their captain was down.
He can't win the fight, but you're starting to see...
He was all right.
Whether it be the individual player going into the 2v1 or the two players that are trying to set up counter angles to the final player remaining.
Really serious stuff here in our final map of this fight.
He zooms, though.
Let's see if it keeps going, though.
Noemi, not recognizing shifting there.
And that's the first deal of round number two.
Yeah, I mean, if you're not really familiar with the map...
What happened?
What?
Oh, wait.
I think it's more a defend-sided, honestly.
Because, like, Jez's team did really well in defend.
In general.
Jez is actually just doing everything.
Marshy's found, and yet again, just Adrian alive.
Just like that?
Tall ass for Lil' A.
Team up 2-0.
Adrian?
What's Adrian doing?
He tries to rush on, but he has Aiden there.
He's got Jez there.
He's got the whole team.
I just ran past him.
I was like, who is he?
Was that Bane?
Bro, the other guy was like, huh?
Bro, I don't know if he was a...
Was that a strat?
It's like, you know when they, like, sent...
Oh, you know how when they, like, sent a clone out, but they, like, Jez sent a real person out?
Jez, though, looking to try an answer on back.
Machine pistol.
It's a little bit too hot.
The accidental strat.
Where did he go?
I can't tell if he was a bait or not.
Maybe take out the main man himself and Marshy.
He's gonna smartly not take that fight, though.
Yeah, he knows that's Marshy.
He saw the movement, and he's like, I'll wait here.
He's like, I'll wait here.
I know who that is.
Oh, Jez has to 1v3 now.
That sucks, because his Mi Shields are all dead.
His Mi Shields keep dying before he can use them.
I think...
How many points is it?
I don't remember.
No, he didn't have the bomb.
Like, his teammates who have the bomb.
I feel like...
I feel like Jez should have the bomb.
Honestly.
I feel like his team just dies way too fast.
I think that they got a handful of wins in the last S&D and did so in a pretty meaningful way.
Like, I know Jez is, like, their team...
Their, like, fragger.
But, like, at this point, it feels like...
It feels like Jez should hold on to it.
And getting those early picks repeatedly.
This time it is age-free, and usually it is...
Oh, oh, a target 7.
Oh, that's what it means.
Sorry, I'm dumb.
This time, though, it's more trades than anything else.
Both teams down to two players.
2-2.
Good job, though, from gamers to not let that lead get away from them when it comes to the lives.
So, being able to even on up and do a 2v2 is here.
Oh.
Marshall's down!
It's over!
Is there, like...
What?
Oh, wait.
Just go to B.
Why don't they just go to B?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was just like...
Just go B.
I'm planning.
You know I'm planning?
I was gonna be like...
Are you okay?
I like this.
Jez is just kind of sliding around.
Trying to run at an intense pace just to clear out any of these angles.
And, well, Jez has a strong opportunity.
Oh?
You might catch him on the cross.
I don't know if you did.
Okay.
Nice little nade there.
Is Aiden gonna die from the frag?
I swear to God, if I see Aiden...
I was like...
Aiden, move!
Why is he just standing there?
Did he take the nade?
Oh, ow.
I was like...
What is he doing?
Why is he...
I guess he missed.
Yeah, how did you miss that?
Yeah, you're...
I feel like...
This is what I also don't like about Search and Destroy game mode.
Is that you have to have really good map knowledge.
I hate...
Like, I hate lurkers.
It's what's created such a contentious and close start to this match.
Ooh.
Again, this was the tipping point for momentum last time.
And they are the ones with the first kill here.
Oh!
Did it...
Jez got two.
Yeah, this is what started to happen.
Oh, is that the AWP?
Wait, did he AWP that?
We're gonna start seeing the same thing here on Tunisia.
It was...
Did he AWP that?
No, I don't hate...
I don't hate...
...stream lurkers.
I hate...
...tactical shooter lurkers.
...who just...
...walk to the other side.
And then just stay there.
No, guys.
Oh my god.
Wait, Marshy just killed three.
Or two?
Wait, where's the bomb?
Guys, any lurkers in my chat?
You guys are pretty cool too.
Okay.
Broku, you're not a lurker.
You type in chat.
There's a lurker.
That's right.
You know what?
Since you're a lurker, I'll give you VIP.
Guys, that's how much I love lurkers.
And now my entire chat will start lurking.
I'm joking.
Don't do that.
No way.
All right, guys.
You failed my first test.
A lurker will continue lurking.
Now that you've typed in my chat, you're no longer a lurker.
So no VIP for you.
True.
No more lurking.
You failed the first test.
Got him.
Into a 1v4.
Oh, you know the...
Wait, what happened?
I looked away for one second.
It's not going down like this again.
Because I'll be real.
I was starting to think it might be.
But momentum, look.
What happened?
I literally turned around for one second.
Yeah, I mean, listen.
It's, uh...
No surprise to see some of these players...
Three people die to a name?
It's all about the mid-round adjustments in the search and destroy maps.
And it seems like, obviously, Shifty had a strong idea.
At least...
The guys are really cool, though, I admit.
Where you drop the grenade.
Yeah.
It turns out you get three for free.
You immediately put this back in.
What is it?
You have planted the bomb.
I like the prone.
The prone's funny.
He's like, where did he go?
I think so fast.
Where did he go?
Oh!
Maybe I spoke too soon.
No!
We got him!
See, just what I mean!
All he had to do was just walk behind him.
The Call of Duty Opal Pro.
Take a series of 1v1s.
I know we have some talented players here.
You're not...
All he did was just walk behind him.
Half a second there, I really believed.
I thought it was gonna happen.
That was insane.
That was a really good shot.
If they don't push this together, I'm guaranteeing him taking each of these 1v1s.
And luckily enough, they didn't do that.
Again, gamers playing a lot more cohesively right now on the second search...
I'm gonna grab...
Wait, let me check.
The problem is that the snipers seem to be reigning supreme.
Whether it's Jez or Marshy, they are getting these early picks almost every day.
Oh my god, is that an AWP?
Yeah, I mean, this is why we love snipers in-call.
Jesus.
Especially search and destroy.
You're able to watch these crosses.
You're able to bring these first bloods into your favor.
Tied up.
3-3 right now.
The movement is so scary.
They're AWPing across.
The classic.
This one's intense.
This map...
feels like it's much more...
even.
Versus...
Oh!
Oh my god!
Wait, did he nade that?
I don't know, I think it's over.
Jez is down.
Ohhhh...
You put it away.
You find yourself up.
4-3.
They keep getting naded.
I think, like...
Marshy's team...
is smarter because they don't group...
like...
in search and destroy, they don't group up.
So, they don't get, like, randomly naded.
Jez's team is, like, for some reason, all, like...
congested into one area.
Somehow.
I don't know how they keep doing that.
I...
I don't understand.
...where everybody has at least 4 or 5.
Look on the other side for momentum.
And again, it is still struggle bus from everybody but Jez.
He has almost 20 kills.
What?
And as high as on his team, not even 4.
Yeah.
Jez is helping...
They don't know the map, too.
I think it's also because they don't know the map as well.
Jez was seen pistol in the hand.
Like, Jez has, like...
is literally, like, carrying his entire team right now.
Like...
His team...
Aw...
His team doesn't push with him!
Another kill onto Huskers, and just like that...
He has to, like...
1...
1v5 everybody all the time.
So the fact that the gamers are...
They either die before the push, or they don't push with him.
If you really want to...
As long as you get that...
Marshy's team's actually all getting kills.
You can tell.
Jez's team only, like, 1 kill.
1, 1, 2.
He's a load.
Jez, what happened?
You used to be so good at baiting!
What happened?
Get those kills.
Adrian's gonna take one.
Marshy's gonna get one as well.
Unfortunately, Adrian will go down for the trade here as Jez is still continuing to be a force to be reckoned with.
Noemi, though, might have shown more than she should have as Marshy's got the rotation out.
If he can find her, he's got the kill, but he said they're gonna play patiently.
And it's actually gonna be a trade across the board.
Shifty and Jez, the last two.
It's one view.
Oh!
Oh, Shifty!
Shifty actually got the rainbows down!
Jez, come on!
You used to be such a good beater!
What happened?
Oh, man.
They're falling apart.
Guys, I think it's over.
I think it's over.
They're falling apart.
Just no more.
No highlight reel.
No highlight reel for you, I guess.
Oh, unless...
Okay, Husker's actually fragging now.
Well, they have the bomb.
They don't have to move anywhere.
Jez doesn't care.
He's like, where are you?
Oh, my God.
Jez is like, where is he?
I didn't scared.
Oh, why?
Why?
Just...
Fight on the bomb!
Okay, Jez is fighting on the bomb now.
He's not moving anymore.
He knows he's lost too many people.
Stop moving!
Like, why...
Why would you move?
You know where the bomb is.
Oh, my God.
Okay, his teammates are actually so stupid.
Like, for that play.
I feel like...
Like, that play was actually dumb for his team to do.
Like, just stay where the bomb is.
You don't have to hunt.
Especially when you know Marshy's the one that's...
Like, at that point, like, Marshy's hunting you.
You're probably like...
No, dude.
You actually are.
You cannot be taken down.
Oh!
Oh, my goodness.
A little critical earlier.
Oh, my God.
And a two.
And a wallbang.
Okay, that...
That is insane.
That is a really good...
That is a good kill.
He needed that.
I hope it goes 6-6.
I really hope it goes 6-6.
Because, like...
That's an insane lineup.
This shit...
I want...
I want this to be a...
Um...
6-6.
He just needs to win one more...
After this.
Okay.
No...
Noemi needs to stop running in a straight line.
All I'm saying is that...
Whoever is Noemi...
They need to stop running in a straight line.
Yeah.
You gotta win those two rounds in...
The fact that...
That they survived that was...
It was an accomplishment.
They mess up in...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Not that Nance.
Oh!
She's down!
Wait!
Wait, it could...
Okay, wait.
I don't want to jinx it.
Caster's curse.
I hope it goes to 6-6, though.
There's at least one down.
Why did he not shoot?
Oh, no.
Husker's down.
Husker's their best player.
Their second...
Their actual best player.
That's not good.
Yeah.
Oh!
All of a sudden...
May not seem like Aiden wants to stay out of the conversation.
Husker's and Jez have gotten a ton.
But goodness me, Jez and Aiden combining for a heck of a lot.
Just Adrian left.
We may see some overtime.
I like how you say Jez and Aiden...
The curse.
Wait, someone help me.
Oh, Aiden did it!
Aiden did it!
It's over time.
It's over time now.
Oh, games are rough...
Tough now.
They tie us on up.
So...
Here we go, ladies and gentlemen.
It is a win by...
Final round!
From here on out.
This is not like your classic multiplayer search and destroy.
There is no...
Oh, my God.
These lineups are crazy.
Adrian are...
Oh, my God.
I hate you, Till.
What is this?
Down with, you, Till.
Cut down, you, Till.
Yes, indeed.
Three players out.
And connected on the verge of taking, I believe, five straight if they get this one.
All I'm saying is...
Oh, my God.
Marshy can...
They're choking.
They're actually choking.
I hate it when I can't see the screen.
Oh.
Okay, just...
Wait.
Oh, they're attacking.
Okay.
So, Marshy has to...
Marshy has to...
Oh!
Oh, my God.
That was a good shot.
I think...
Okay.
For overtime, they should just get rid of all names.
Use pure skill.
It should be, like, pure skill for overtime.
The individual abilities combined with the team abilities.
That's all I'm saying.
Just pure skill.
No util.
Oh!
That wall bang.
That was a good wall bang.
I don't know.
The last time we saw gamers were the first kill of the round.
Yeah, huge first blood from them to be able to snag that.
That's a good wall bang.
Like, he predicted...
He predicted that, too.
Which is crazy.
Both teams respecting each other.
For the moment.
Great shots.
Oh!
Chaz gets fouled up by Marshy.
Wait.
How did they, like, get him...
How did they do that?
Like, what happened?
Oh, no.
They got the rate bosses down.
That's bad.
They need to kill Marshy because he's, like, four people.
They killed four people!
All I'm saying, he's basically four.
Oh, Shifty got...
No.
Unless Husker can 1v2.
But it's hard because they have crossfire.
He has to rush him.
No!
He can't.
Bro, he couldn't turn in time.
Oh, another overtime.
Keep it going.
This is...
This is rough.
This is intense.
I think it's because, like, their teammates are now understanding the map as well.
Yeah.
Huskers needs to up his sense.
That was, like, low sense debuff right there.
I can't be the same.
He couldn't turn around in time.
It does feel like they've got a bit more of a reserved game.
You can see it.
Both teams not willing to dive to a...
Oh!
But Jez and threw the wall shot.
They had a better new...
How?
That's actually...
That's always crazy to see.
Wall bangs are scary as hell.
You saw it on Express.
We see it here on...
Check his thumbs!
Remove the sleeves!
See what's under there.
...puts gamers into the 4v5.
As they're starting to spread on out.
I think if you are gamers, though, you do just have this ability...
...where you can kind of just spread the map if you want.
What the...
What is he?
3v4.
You see, you have a couple members...
Jez is like...
He's...
Marci's like, I'm right behind you.
I know you're there.
I see your running ass right there.
I see you running.
4.
I mean, he's gotten close to turning this around before.
We saw him.
Oh, no.
Oh, it's...
It's...
Well, just stay...
Stay on point.
Just stay on point.
Is he going to try to play this one aggressively or will he play a bit more reserved?
He knows he's going to...
Just stay on point.
So, he's going to hustle and have shots fired at him.
Not going to even be concerned...
I feel like both teams are just really good at Ty.
...try to rotate on him now that they have his position.
Yeah.
He almost had a solid time...
...to kill the player off...
There's too many people alive.
You know, obviously, if you can manage to make that happen...
Another overtime.
Jesus.
...scramble a little bit.
There's so much overtime.
...use that to your advantage.
Catch somebody trying to push on in.
Grab the bomb, but...
Nice.
A little too late.
So, the bomb does get planted and he kind of has to play this way.
Okay, we...
There should be.
I told you.
They should all just get rid of you two during overtime.
Oh, they're not...
They're not looking through it anymore.
...that we've seen.
Do you catch Aiden down below here?
I think you get a little bit of...
Oh, it's too late.
He didn't rotate in time.
Flash onto Jez.
He's actually not going to catch this.
You got three players down below you, though.
He might get a little bit too aggressive.
He's down.
I think all of them are bad at...
Offense.
We could keep going.
Feels like we could be here all day.
Both teams continuing to trade back and forth.
Whether first blood or just kills in between.
We've seen trade after trade.
This time, though, a little bit different.
It is gamers who get not only the advantage...
We might have to go...
Trying to take on the whole team.
Maybe not realizing they're completely on that stairwell.
Oh, he missed.
Wait, Marsh is down, though.
And this could change everything.
This could change everything.
Oh, wait.
They got the rain.
They got the four players.
Wait, don't let Jess die.
Don't let him die.
He's your fourth.
He's equal to six players.
He's six players.
Oh, he did it!
Just did it!
Bro, he's double Marshall's kills.
He's actually double Marshall's kills.
That's crazy.
Bro, bro, don't emote.
You gotta thank your carry.
All I'm saying...
All I'm saying, thank your carry.
The overconfident emote.
Wait, that's Jess?
Is that Jess?
Okay, no.
Wait, that is Jess.
He has the thumbs.
Okay, you deserve the emote.
I saw the thumbs leaves.
Never mind.
I thought that other one was Jess.
Emote as much as you want.
I have to look for the thumbs leaves.
Player cameras is dapping up everybody.
Giving them high fives.
I couldn't tell.
I forgot what they...
I forgot which one was the captain.
Gotta give some credit to gamers.
They don't show the cam.
All the way to a map five.
Emo, as much as you want, Jess.
You literally doubled, like...
You doubled Marshy's kills.
Two rounds back-to-back.
It's gonna be three, two...
In the favor of...
Marshy might be four players, but Jess was, like, ten.
Not going home empty-handed.
$17,500 for them.
They'll get to walk home with...
Yeah, they get 3K.
They get to just watch a magic show.
Getting ready to go up against...
In Viva Las Vegas.
In the grand finals.
Absolutely insane to see here.
Definitely, definitely warranted.
This was beyond deserved to make...
I thought the other guy was Jess.
Because I thought they, like, put the captains at the end of the desk.
Unless he wasn't.
Guys.
Which one was Jess?
Was it the guy that had the thumbs-leaves?
Or was it, like, the guy next to him...
At the end of the table?
I couldn't tell.
Yes.
Because I thought they would be, like...
At the end of the table.
Because, uh...
Marshy was at the end of the table.
It's that one.
Here I'd be asking...
Hey, Gemini.
What are some ways to calm myself down?
It would be funny if, like...
The non-pro is wearing the thumbs-leaves.
Hi.
My name is Jess.
And these are some commo-able tips and tricks.
Oh, there you are.
Go, Jess.
Go.
Specifically, video settings.
When competing at any level...
Certain settings can be the difference...
Between winning and losing.
Let's take a look at some specific ones...
You should consider using.
Jess tips.
First off, we'll be taking a look at...
Graphics quality and frame rate.
Take your notes, guys.
You can play just like him.
And by the way, he is playing on...
Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Oh my god.
Just like the Ultra.
Smooth and quality gaming experience.
Next, we have Explosion Shape.
You want this option off to prevent disorientation and difficulty aiming.
This is something you will not want to experience mid-gunfire.
More FPS means more...
No, that is true.
More FPS means more gaming.
100% true.
I agree.
You are able to change the look of your game from this...
We all saw what happened to me during the rhythm game.
You guys were like, you're just bad, Doki.
But the moment I played...
With 240 frames...
I beat the game.
It was not the placebo effect.
Did they?
That's wild.
But what about my...
What about my...
Jest tips?
I can't, guys.
I can't.
It's part of it.
My jest tips!
But thank you, Samson.
Wait, that was it?
From the jest tips?
Oh, I thought there were more jest tips.
I thought there were more jest tips.
I guess that's...
The thing ended...
Very abruptly.
I didn't realize...
That was all the tips he was gonna give us.
I thought he had more stuff to say.
But I guess that was it.
He's just that good, guys.
He's just that good.
If you can't perform like him...
After all those...
Like, direct informational jest tips...
Then it's on you.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
All right, we have seven minutes...
To kill before the next...
Before you taking a picture of, sir.
I'm gonna turn this down a little bit.
I'm gonna use the bathroom...
During this break.
I'll be right back, guys.
And I need more water.
I'll be right back.
What happened?
Wait, were they...
Were home...
Were bros being bros?
What happened?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Nothing.
Uh, Zookarack, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Just bros being bros.
Our man missed out?
Why is he looking at us?
Because he thinks you're cute, guys.
Will you help a homie out?
Flushed?
Me?
Oh, there's so many people there.
Did you hear about the...
The...
Uh...
Wait, actually, I don't know if I can talk about it.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I'll talk about it in another stream.
Ha ha ha ha!
That's right.
I left you at a cliffhanger.
What do you...
What does she mean?
Hear about what, Doki?
Find out next time.
On the next stream.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Guess we'll never know.
Ha ha ha ha!
What does she mean?
What does
she mean?
I can talk about the support strike.
Alright, so you know how, like, okay, I find it funny, um, because people are assuming that support players are on a strike right now.
Because they're, like, they're, like, from just one reddit post or whatever.
Um, this is something different, what I wanted to talk about.
No, okay, so, like, apparently, okay, for, this is, like, basically, uh, Marvel Rivals drama.
But there's support players, there's, people are so convinced that support players are on strike.
And I'm, like, uh, no.
I'm, like, I am pretty sure that it's not an actual strike.
That, like, you know, a lot of players don't go on Reddit.
People just don't want to play.
Like, if a game is not fun, we just don't play the game.
Like, it's not necessarily a strike.
It's just, we just thought it wasn't fun.
And we can't play as long.
So, people are complaining and basically complaining about, um, dive meta being, like, really difficult.
Which, I agree, like, it is a lot difficult to play in the newest meta.
And I honestly think, I think it's just the, I, I think, like, it's just way too tiring.
So, I don't play as long.
Because, um, I thought, I just think the game is just, took too much of my mental capacity to play for longer, like, longer hours.
So, I log off faster.
And I just don't think it is a strike.
I just think people just don't play as long anymore for support players.
Because it's just not fun.
Like, if the game is fun, then we'll play longer.
But if it's not, then we don't.
Like, also, like, um, also, I would agree.
No, the rank points is actually so messed up.
Um, I won a game where I was solo support.
I was playing, so, I was solo support.
The enemy team was, was an actual cop.
And I was solo support.
And I got plus 17 points.
After I won the game.
And then my DPS player got plus 27.
I, after I solo, there was, by the way, It was four DPS, one, four DPS, one tank, Mia solo support.
We, and this was a GM3 game, too.
So, GM3 to GM, GM3 to GM1.
And I still got plus 17.
Because, for those who don't know, The rank point distribution is based off damage.
So, yeah, as the solo support, I wasn't doing enough damage Because I had to heal four DPS.
And I was on, I was on Sue.
Yeah, I can't.
So, like, I can see why it's not fun, too.
Because you're not climbing.
But, like, that, that, I didn't care as much until that game.
Because I was like, what's the point?
Like, I don't get rewarded for playing out of my frickin' mind As the only support player.
Like,
no rank ruins for me.
That, like, actually, that was the one that pissed me off the most.
Um, and people figured out it had to do with damage.
The correlation between damage and Rank points, because They, they're doing a hotfix Patch.
I don't know when they're patching it, but The new patch In the, in the new patch They're doing a hotfix or something In the new balance patch Before the season ends And they're buffing support DPS 20 players So then you know it's correlated.
Because why would they buff support DPS?
Found
ourselves now here At the grand finals A hundred thousand dollars Oh my god, it's Paris!
Oh my god We're in Paris!
Let's get my first time for our grand final!
Yeah!
Thank you, Samson!
It has been an incredible day We had four different teams compete in this one We are down to two We've seen some intense action so far here today And it's looked great every step of the way Thanks!
Yeah, just increase DPS The supports can do more DPS Again, we want to give a massive shout out To Samsung today With the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra's Customized processor You're getting the most powerful processor ever In a Galaxy phone Yeah!
I mean, it looks really good The Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra For the Call of Duty Mobile Like, it just looks like Like, the gameplay for it looks really good And like, so many people I saw so many people in chat was like Wait, is that like on Is this on PC?
And everyone's like No, it's on mobile Like, people are like Wait, this is on mobile?
The processor's really strong Like, was it the Snapdragon 8?
I believe First place, taking home 30,000 split amongst 5 players Second place, taking home Yeah, and that's like 120Hz I think that's the most impressive part for me That's 120Hz They are competing for an additional $15,000 In a 1v1 And I could not be more excited for it We have found ourselves As I mentioned before Our final eight competitors here Two teams Both of which Have battled it out One Captain Captain by our boy Space The other one Captain By Jez Two Call of Duty mobile Professional gamers One of which A world championship Within the last year But only one of them Wait,
who's the world champion?
Is it Jez?
Wait
Who's the world champion?
That doesn't seem quite fair Nebula Knights Were able to take that 3-0 Over their competitors And in our second semifinal We found ourselves A much closer back and forth But It's enough of me It's time to throw To our casters It's to Dandro To Agent And to Dylan Take it away For our grand final Yo,
what is up everybody?
What's up?
Dude, you are bringing the energy I love it Big time Already, I've been watching I mean, they've been Watching since for like This is like, what?
The 5th hour for them?
For 5th hour?
And they started like They started like 2 hours before me What's up?
I think I'm just excited To see the Call of Duty maps My favorite It's like a legacy game Yeah We got some maps coming up We'll talk about it Don't worry But obviously You guys just saw Bass on the stage You have Dylan here with me And we got one more guest That's actually joining us As well Who?
I think he's walking in right now Apparently he's famous Or something I don't know Somebody told me to say that I'm not Who is he?
It's our boy Agent Yo How's it going everybody?
How's it going?
What's up man?
It's nice to be back in the booth Man, it's been a year Since I've conversated You were telling me earlier You were like I'm excited to do this Because I used to do this Back in the day This was my dream growing up Like I went to school For sport management And I worked on the camera ops team And I applied to be doing this And they told me not Now I'm doing it man I'm here Now he does it for free
I feel like we won't hire you, but you can do this for free as a surprise guest.
Tell us a little bit about those first qualifiers, because you were saying you were watching some of those games earlier.
His casters are getting paid.
Official casters, too.
First of all, everybody here is better than me.
As soon as anything better than me, I'm already impressed.
I love watching good Call of Duty.
It's such an exciting game to watch.
You can make plays happen.
I don't know which...
I assume the coach team is the one that got instant eliminated, right?
Commentators!
She's relaxed as hell.
That's the gamer posture right there.
They lose.
They go into overtime.
I mean, they put up a hell of a fight.
But unfortunately, it's just not enough.
But yeah, I mean, it was just kind of like all cylinders firing.
I think what I love for momentum in a couple of those qualifiers is just like...
Jesus.
That looks like cheating.
I like the 1v1s.
The 1v1s have to be like...
Wait!
It was!
That guy...
I knew it!
He took off his...
He took off his thumb sleeves!
Bro!
I knew it!
I knew that was chess!
Who's the other guy?
He took off his thumb sleeves.
I second doubted myself.
I knew that wasn't chess!
But at least he's trying.
You know?
At least he's trying.
At least he's like trying, you know?
He's actually like committed to this.
Like he bought the thumb sleeves.
You can see there, it always went to the game 9.
We will touch it on up and make it.
Okay.
A little bit about this bracket.
Yeah.
A little bit of bracket, okay?
We saw Nebula Knights there in our first game.
3-0.
Notorious.
It wasn't even close.
Absolutely cooked it.
You know?
They've been on ice.
They've been waiting.
They haven't even been able to play.
Oh!
Second time.
Game 5.
Momentum.
I'm looking up.
I want to know like...
It's another best of 5.
I just want to know.
Like...
What are we...
What's...
Who's on whose team?
That's all I want to know.
I think Nebula Knights is going to come in like cocky.
They just got 3-0.
But Momentum had to fight for their win.
So they're like all cylinders...
Okay, Momentum is more warmed up.
I feel like Momentum as a team is much more warmed up.
3-0?
Momentum?
I say...
I say 3-1 Momentum.
3-1 Momentum.
I lowkey agree with that take, Dylan.
I'm going to look at the previous 5.
Now granted, I didn't get a chance to see Nebula Knights play too much.
I saw here and there.
But I watched a good amount of that last game.
So...
I'm pretty confident.
If they can play like that against gamers, like...
They should have it in the bag.
Plus like...
It's like when you beat a team too early.
And now you got an extra, extra long break.
Oh yeah.
And sometimes your fingers are a little cold.
You know...
Oh yeah.
This...
Guys, the coach's team was the one that got 3-0.
Guys.
The coach's team was the one.
They got that...
Yeah, they got knocked that instantly.
Okay.
This team...
I'm looking at it.
Nebula Knights is Space's team.
So this is Space and this is Jez.
I knew it!
That was Jez!
I see their pictures now!
It has their pictures!
I knew it!
Guys...
Or a...
Vibe check was the strat, guys.
It was all about the vibes.
Yeah, no.
The pros were definitely very important.
They like...
They put the entire team on their backs.
But like, I feel like, okay, but Marsha's team, they had the better team...
They had the better, like, overall team players versus Jez, but it was him.
I thought this... we all were debating if this was Jez or not.
It was this guy.
Wait!
Wait a minute!
I'm not gonna say it.
I remember the kill score.
I remember the team score.
I'm not gonna say it.
He was killing them all the call-outs for Express.
He was letting them know exactly what it was, like, what we're calling these.
He knows exactly how to play these maps.
I think Raiden's a good shout.
Yeah, I agree.
I think Raiden is there.
I want to give some credit, though.
I feel like...
Huskers is really good, though.
Huskers is really good.
I mean, he was a Call of Duty pro in general, so it transfers over.
I don't really know, like, the other players here.
I know Huskers is good.
He can be able to kind of cook there, so...
For sure.
Very, very excited as we get ready.
I mean, he was their second fragger, too.
Who's your projected MVP?
Okay, if I'm going...
Okay, I'm not picking a Call of Duty mobile pro.
I feel like that's...
Yeah, yeah, no, no, no.
I feel like it's too.
It's like, oh, the guy who's played this forever.
Yeah, he's probably gonna do the best on the map.
Wait, who is it?
I don't know who it is.
I don't know, man.
I think I'm gonna go with Aiden.
I think he did a really good job.
He turned up in that...
Like, I'm like, I don't know who it is.
Who's been around longer?
He's kind of, like, playing his life really well.
You have to explain this from someone who doesn't know.
Great stuff as we get ready to move on into the grand finals.
Now, grand finals is not the only thing that we're doing.
Show match.
Don't make me Google.
I'm not gonna lie, I'm most excited for that.
You're most excited for that?
I love 1-1.
Mike Wazowski.
He didn't tell us who it is.
Cover him up.
He didn't tell me.
Put the PNG up.
All right, well, guess what?
Our teams are ready to go.
Grand finals, ready to get started.
We're gonna kick it over to Bass to help introduce our teams.
Yeah.
All right, ladies and gentlemen.
We have our...
Wait, they removed it after it's done.
That's funny.
There's no other than Momentum.
Jez, Aiden, Huskers, Santana, and Noemi.
Woo!
Let's go.
In your booth you go.
In the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra booth.
Jez, Huskers, and Friends.
Okay, look.
It's Jez, Huskers, and Friends.
All right.
And for our second team.
The Nebula Knights.
Space, Lucky, Isaac, Rated, and Primrose.
Bum, bum, bum, ba-dum, bum, ba-dum, bum, bum, ba-dum, bum, ba-dum, bum, bum, bum.
That is like some boss music right there.
Into the next booth you go.
Bum, bum, bum, ba-dum, bum, ba-dum, bum, ba-dum, bum, ba-dum, bum, bum.
All right.
Let's get ready for our grand finals.
Casters, one last time.
Take it away.
Wow.
What a good job that man Bastos yelling about our teams.
Jumping on in.
Hey, listen.
He had to kind of do that last minute.
So I'm glad he was able to clutch it on up.
All right.
Game number one.
We're getting ready to hop on in.
I actually don't know, production.
We can pull up the maps of what we are playing.
Wait.
Guys.
Apparently, Marshy was like...
Wait.
Actually, I'm looking at winnings.
All right.
I'm looking at winnings, but...
Marshy has the most winnings out of like...
All the players.
But he still lost to Jez.
So...
I think Jez is the one that's been around the longest.
Because it says he's played...
29...
I'm actually looking this up because I got really curious.
I was like...
Who is like the most well-known pro in this tournament?
Where the heck is space?
Does he go by a different name?
I'm hoping we at least go four.
That's why I'm really like...
Me too.
You know what's funny?
Jez is the one that doesn't put his age out.
I'm looking at the...
I'm looking at the esports...
And...
And like...
It shows everybody's age.
Oh, I guess like...
Tectonic doesn't have his age out either.
I don't know where...
I don't know how Tectonic is.
One, firing range, search and destroy.
And if we get to those last two maps...
Hacienda Harpo...
But Jez doesn't have his age.
Coincidence?
I think not.
Where's space?
Call of Duty, mobile pros, space.
I'm also kind of curious how...
Firing range...
Oh, he has a Liquipedia.
I mean, that's like...
That is a throwback.
It's still saying Black Ops 2...
Right, right.
Oh, wait.
Did he transition to...
No.
Oh, he's retired.
Okay, we know who's going to win then.
Guys.
It seems like space is the retired player.
And Jez is still competing.
Alright, this might be...
Alright, let's do a...
Let's do a prediction, guys.
I think this is the perfect time for a prediction, now.
I already do a prediction, I don't remember.
Slash...
Prediction.
I mean, it is.
Is this kind of like a nice...
Alright.
Start prediction.
Jez.
The non-retired pro...
Versus space.
You can't be...
Who is retiring.
Oh, wait.
Sometimes you just got to, though.
Sometimes it works.
Sometimes you get benched.
Do you like your odds?
Unfortunately, uh...
You just kind of have to suck here.
You can't get benched.
You're just bottom frag for your team.
Yeah.
Your squad's looking at you.
It's costing us $10,000.
Here goes all my points.
You don't want to be the one to call it that.
No, it doesn't.
I'm going to put my entire savings.
Because it's kind of insane when we talk about the bracket, man.
Hey, look.
Look.
Maybe I'm just saying that so I can...
I vote for space.
Maybe I lied.
Just so I can win the bet.
Just so I can yoink all your points.
I could have just lied about that.
How would you know?
You're not going to Google it yourself?
Sounds like turkey.
I love that.
And then obviously, after our bracket, we got that show match.
Dylan's excited for it.
Oh, wow.
10 for the show match.
10 for the show.
So it's kind of crazy because like Bass was talking about it.
Already making it here.
The captain is already secured at least $4,000.
I was like curious.
I was like, wait.
Okay, let me look up.
20 grand.
I'm saying at least by getting here.
But then you go into the show match.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you're taking over at least another five.
So if you're one of these captains, you've secured at least nine grand.
Wait, how old is it?
Which sometimes is not so good for your hunger and overall...
I think...
All right.
All those who actually looked up their Liquipedia will know why I laughed.
I looked up both Space and Jez's Liquipedia.
Now I know why Jez is really, really good.
Now I know why.
Now I realize why.
I want to talk to the players here, man.
Players, there's a lot of money on the line.
This is no joke.
You don't want to be...
I don't want to let your team down.
You're all gamers.
Just some of you are better gamers.
Goodbye, my point.
Tell us.
I'll tell you guys after the prediction's over.
Oh, it's over.
I'll tell you after this game is over.
Banging it out.
Oh, unless...
I mean...
We're kind of worried with this team.
Wait, wait.
A little bit.
Are they going to come out swinging?
Wait.
Oh, never mind.
Just got him down.
Oh, wait.
He's going to have to...
Not just lead in terms of kills.
He's going to have to lead in terms of communication as well.
All right.
Let's see him.
The thing I'm always looking to do is like the spawns.
Oh, my God.
What?
Goddamn, like, anchor dropped on them.
They're kind of spawning deep, right?
Just come on.
I need the points.
Great job of being able to kind of hopefully get in on this hill.
It's a couple early points, though.
Yeah, it goes hard points.
1v1.
And then, um...
What is Lucky doing?
What is that strat?
Yeah, this is definitely a tough one.
You're trying to have to sacrifice yourself for the betterment of the team.
I'm not doing it.
I'm an objective player.
So, like, I'm happy to got to leave my life.
What was that?
I'm not that player.
You slayer?
I'm an islet.
I'll just take that ball and I'll clean up after you.
I'll always clean up, though.
You got it, dude.
Yeah, you got me, though.
Go, Jez, go.
That's some good teamwork.
That's what you want.
Exactly.
You need the OBJ guy.
Okay, who has a point right now, though?
Okay, it's Jez's team.
Alright.
So, I'll tell you why.
If Space's team wins this, they honestly are...
What is going...
Wait, did he got locked?
Did he got util-ed?
Okay, the reason why I think if Space's team wins this, then, like, um, overall team might be better.
Because, and, like, he might have just, like, locked in, like, because he knows it's, like, 30 grand.
He might have locked in really, really hard.
But the reason why I was, like, oh, my God, is because I looked at Space has made total winnings so far.
Um, yeah, he's, like, the underdog right now.
Is that he has made 27k in total winnings.
Now, if we look at Jez...
Now, let me pull up Jez on the other hand, who is not retired yet.
He may or may not have won $146,000.
Oh!
So, I was, like, if Space does this, like, he deserves, like, he is truly the underdog right now.
Do it again!
Dude, he's still gone.
One more, what else?
The rest of his face, my boys, right from the start.
I mean, look, it's pretty close, guys.
Space might just have the better team, in general.
But, like, the 1v1 is where we're gonna see it.
The 1v1 is where we're gonna see the true, true game thing.
He plays on what's called six-finger claw.
So, he literally uses, like, his, I don't know, his middle finger, his index, and his thumb.
Well, that's the point right now.
I can't tell.
Okay, it's Space's team.
It is pretty close, guys.
Guys, it is pretty close.
They're going, that are doing something.
They might, he might do it.
I mean, there's really not, I mean, I'm trying to watch this.
I've never been happy in the midst of both.
The midst of both.
They're doing a good job.
They brought it back to roughly a 50-point game, which isn't true.
Yeah, I'm just trying to give you false hope right now.
I'm into it, but I think the Knights are just...
What is, what is, what is I didn't doing?
I, it's just like, yeah, bye.
This is a cold game.
I was like, don't worry, Jess got this.
Oh my god, bro, she just burned him alive.
She was like, you're, no movement for you.
I liked how, I liked how, um, Space's team was like, I, screw movement.
Screw your movement.
I'm just gonna burn you.
If you're ready to head on over to this next hill.
No, the coach, no, every other pro, other than the coach's team, based it off of vibes.
Um, the coach's team got eliminated instantly.
Yes, back to the middle, and I won't die, man.
They got flag jacket.
Uh, some of them do, yeah.
The coach's team got 3-0.
I googled.
Not googled.
I looked at the vibe.
Because, like, because, like, this team, like, a lot of it is, like, heavy, uh, the coach couldn't, uh, obviously, is not, like, at the same skill level as, like, the pros, because, you know, he's a coach.
So, like, a lot of, like, depends on, like, kills as well.
I was just gonna, like, some of those...
Hills are, like, any time you get on this P1, it's just braving, right?
Like, you're, like, alright, cool, like...
Guys, it's okay, guys.
Space still has the 1v1.
It's gonna be all about, like, the move over to...
I love, I love that anchor gun.
That's so funny.
Yeah, they was able to break the hill, though.
It just, like, throws an anchor.
Like, uh...
Yeah, in the end, they all get money in the end, which is good.
But, like, you were mentioning, they don't have that much practice together.
So, even if they're individually fantastic...
Wait, who?
If together, they don't have much experience, sometimes...
Space's team?
Like, hardpoint...
Uh, on a mode like hardpoint, you need that chemistry.
To be fair, I also think Jez's team is gonna win.
Because they played longer together during the final...
Like, the...
During the...
Three...
During, like, you know, they went to overtime and everything.
So, their team has longer time to bond.
Jeez.
Yeah, and they just played...
Oh, wait, that's true.
They just played.
And then...
Space has to warm up.
And then, Space just killed everybody.
Space and Raided just killed everybody.
Yeah, I think...
They have better teamwork, for sure.
I feel.
I think...
Raided is better than Huskers.
Yeah.
At the moment.
At this point...
Just cause like...
Kill...
Like, fragging wise...
He has...
His second fragger is better.
They're kinda showing some signs of life here.
They've brought it back into a 60 point game.
What's going on?
Oh, what the hell?
Oh!
What?
Panicked right there.
Wide open.
Oh God.
Oh, new point.
That's the one thing, is that like, obviously, your thumbs can slip.
Yeah!
Yeah, they can!
Get those thumbs sleeves, guys!
Exclamation point, Samson!
Yeah!
Thumbs sleeves!
Oh!
Bro, they just walked in!
That's so fast!
What, they're just dead?!
Already?!
That was so fast!
That actually happened so fast!
Oh, he got the gloves!
He got the gloves!
I noticed not a lot of people are meleeing at all.
I like this though, Husker.
Gets us some good shots.
Teammates able to help follow it on up.
Oh, they got the point back!
Nice!
Oh, my God!
Space is... Space is just nailing everybody!
Jess, where are you?
Save him!
I'm squeezing out all this time.
I found them, seeing if you can rotate in time.
He's catching up.
Oh, never mind.
He lost a point.
They're right back in there.
Oh!
We bust down.
Bring it back to... Wait, is that a new point?
For them.
They were down a lot.
Oh, wait!
They got back!
Iceman Isaac will get takedown by a predator drone.
Yup.
Probably not exactly what you want to see, but...
Let's see if Nebula can break it here.
This is gonna be a pretty deciding factor.
That would've been crazy if you got that off.
I love, like, the grenade launcher there.
I need to see the cam in there.
Here we go.
Okay.
That gotta be the better.
The akimbo pistol is slaying.
The dual pistol seems so strong.
There's zero recoil.
Wait, is there zero recoil?
He's holding down fire and moving close.
That's so strong.
Is it, like, points to get it?
In his close quarters.
Oh, my!
Did he drone himself?
You love to see it.
On the inside, at least you get the two before you take it on out.
What did he do?
What was that?
I guess I broke it, but it looks like momentum's gonna early rotate to the next hill.
Smart when you're up this much.
Yeah, momentum's doing a good job of maintaining.
Oh, killstreak.
...hold on the lead here.
It goes up to 250?
Yeah, it goes to 250, man.
It's definitely 250.
They can't possibly choke this.
Sorry, sometimes I say stuff like that just to see if...
I didn't even know they say it commentator is there.
I don't know.
There's no way they'll choke this.
Like, you hope that they lose it now?
And you say, there's no way they choke this, right?
There's definitely a way they can choke it.
Oh, yeah, there always is a way, especially in hardpoint.
I'm like, okay, so, like, we were watching Jez's team for so long, that, like, I keep thinking yellow is him.
So, it's like, it, like, throws me off to find him as blue now.
Where, you know, your physical athleticism plays a huge role.
Like, you could be the greatest at aiming, but when you're on stage...
He's just like, where did he come from?
You could crumble.
That could, that could be the reality.
And sometimes...
Jesus, oh my god, this is the anchor.
The anchor is such a cool gun.
I love, I love the kill animation for that.
The kill animation for the anchor is so funny.
Oh, the nade.
Hold on.
Might have spoke too soon, as Nebula Knight seems to be climbing back in this one.
Down about 20 points here.
Wait, oh, it's close.
It's actually really close.
This one's gonna be super important.
Yeah, look, Raiden has 36 kills.
I just think...
Oh my god, look at the 90 to 62.
Jez is like...
Wait, no Emmy, no Emmy, no Emmy!
Noooo!
That's huge, that's a huge break!
That might be the game, that might be the game, that might be the game.
Is that it?
Oh, unless...
Look at this!
Keep him alive!
Oh!
It's so much!
I see a Kimbo!
Jez absolutely cleared the point here before getting killed.
Keep him alive, guys!
You have to keep...
Oh!
Difference.
They've not made it at all.
Oh no, oh no, they're catching up, they're catching up!
Scrap time, which is sick.
Wait, even if with the scrap time, you'll even...
They're catching up!
Wait, space might actually hold, hold!
Yeah, if I'm...
Space might actually hold this!
Squeeze out the scrap time, I'm trying to...
Oh, it's close, it's too...
Oh, wait, they...
They overtake it!
And they took the lead!
They actually took the lead!
No way!
Let's see if they can find a way...
Guys, by the way, the prediction is per round, guys.
I'm gonna win this one right here.
No!
Space's not my point!
What if I lied about the winnings the entire time?
What if...
What if I lied about it, guys?
No!
226!
It's per round, guys!
You should have read the fine print!
He's insane!
Oh!
39, 40, 42, 43, 46, 47, 48!
You know you ain't won!
Look at the pop-off!
What if I lied about it, guys?
We got scammed!
I'm taking care of you!
My, my, buddy!
No!
They hurt you!
Yeah, that's what I want to say!
Always believed!
Always spit on the underdog, baby!
Oh!
Yes!
Always go against the odds!
All right!
Looks like space one!
Yummy, yummy, money, money!
Wow!
More kills did not equal!
I really need a new phone scene, because my keys are...
Is there anything to say about the Samsung S25 Ultra before I go pick it up?
Oh!
That thank you for the segway!
But yeah!
Um, it does have a large va- larger vapor chamber and upgraded cooling system, so it does help with the...
Also not overheat and stuff.
So yeah!
Thank you!
Thank you for the bitties!
I'm ready!
Thank you!
That's the person below me!
Below you!
Yay!
35k!
Yippee!
Thanks for donating your quads, guys!
I thought about like...
Ha ha ha!
753k!
Damn!
Always bet on the underdogs!
But I think I was dealing with saying like...
All right!
Here we go!
Let's start a new prediction!
Tell me like...
You see...
How they're playing!
And it's like...
All right!
Let's adjust!
So...
For what...
First thing we noticed...
Space!
The underdog!
I'm now...
I'm not...
Myself...
Especially on a hardpoint...
Start prediction!
All right!
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick!
It was...
Are you back?
I think we were a little bit surprised...
To see some of the...
The stuff coming on out there...
Because yeah!
I don't think any of us were...
Literally ready for...
Akimbo Pistols to...
Apparently be the best gun...
Yeah!
You put those in my hands...
I might...
I might get a killer to myself!
I knew the room was cleared...
Whenever I see the Akimbo Pistols come out!
Ha ha ha ha!
If...
Space has that laser...
That point is held!
That point is held or taken!
The...
The Tempest is like...
Because like...
People forget like...
That thing like...
Comes out in Black Ops 4!
And it's just like...
Basically a lightning rifle...
That if it hits anybody...
It's going to stun them!
Right?
And if you manage to get a headshot...
Like you're getting kills with it too!
Yeah!
It's crazy!
Like...
So it's like...
With all those confined spaces...
When he's able to let that thing fly...
He's going to be able to...
To absolutely bring people down!
But map number one man...
Yeah!
I kind of...
Someone call it an upset!
I'm pretty good for this through one!
Some people...
Some people to my left name agent...
Might call that an upset!
You know?
Like...
Who knows?
That's there!
I think...
I think we need to ban you...
From making any more provisions!
But look though!
That made for a great game!
I think game one...
Game one of the finals...
It was cinematic!
You feel me?
Down 100 points!
Clawing their way back!
E point by point by point!
And then clutching it out at the very end!
So we can get more games like that!
We might just go to a game five!
I'd love it!
Yeah!
I mean...
We're here in great finals!
Might as well, right?
Yeah!
Hell yeah!
All right!
Map number two though!
We gotta talk about it!
This is the 1v1 baby!
Yeah!
This is the 1v1!
Now this is all mental!
Realistically!
All mental!
Well this is what I was like telling Bass!
I'm like, if you go down like five kills to your opponent man, like that early on, your mental's checked!
They can break in!
Yeah!
Your mental's checked!
You gotta have like insane just grit to be able to like come back on in and be able to like bring that lead back in your favor!
But you know, we got two very talented players being able to kind of load on in!
We got Space and Jez!
Yeah!
We're now about to go out in that 1v1!
And I'm most excited for this because I feel like, you know, we saw earlier where the two Call of Duty Mobile Pros kind of battled it out super close all the way through!
I think we're gonna be the same here!
Right, right!
Tell us a little bit more about their experience, uh, both Jez and Space!
Yeah!
So, so Space, uh, he was a, a, uh, he went on a 30 tournament win streak in Call of Duty Mobile!
It was crazy!
He also won Call of Duty Mobile World Champs!
And in 2022, uh, Jez...
That's the Wayne Gretzky of Call of Duty Mobile!
Believe it, Jez!
Jez, he's able to, uh, win Call of Duty Mobile Champs!
He actually did it!
Oh, man!
Welcome back guys!
So what?
Come on in!
Always go all in!
After what?
Oh, it's sniper time!
Wait, they're not even using shotguns!
I think I'm taking space for this one!
Yeah, me too!
I know!
I know you got, I can't bet against it!
All right!
The sniper does make a lot of sense on this map!
Should be a lot of head glitching!
3-0!
Yeah, you can do, listen, that's the cool part of the level!
You can do whatever you want!
We allow all the guns!
I think, I think it's cool that they're using snipers instead of shotguns this time!
So we can get...
I miss this map so much!
Okay, I think we know who's the better player!
I think, I think we know mechanically who's better!
I...
Just from, just from the shots alone, from both of them!
Oh, that was a good wallbang though!
That was good!
I think mechanically, mechanically, Jez is definitely better!
Space?
Space, you gotta kinda get some of these...
Oh, I think Jez!
Okay, you know what, I think Jez is being like super cocky!
And he's using the same, he's like, utilizing the same guns that Space is using!
He's, he's playing very cocky right now!
Because he was on sniper!
He's trying to ego, I feel like he's egoing him!
Yeah, because he was like on sniper first, and then he's like, You know what, you're using that gun, I'm gonna use that gun too!
I'm gonna have to fight a war after a 1v1, so...
Especially, just losing that last one, I think momentum...
Jez, stop egoing him!
Hey guys, Space is catching up!
Ha, ha, ha, ha...
Search and destroy, you're down O2...
All the Jez supporters are now being like, NO!
S&D's next?
Fire!
Why did I not vote for Space?
All right, Space, you've been able to...
See look, it's 30,000 on the line.
Yeah.
I'm sitting in the back hardscoping.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
But for 30 bands, I will be sitting in the back hardscoping with my thermal.
You can't stop me.
Hey, listen, you gotta do what you gotta do man.
Money's on the mine.
You do whatever you can.
I'm surprised people haven't swapped over to Space yet.
So committed to this Type 63.
He used it at our crap show during that free fall.
Gerald, you didn't even vote.
You're not even part of the predictions.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Cooking with it.
And he said it was one of his favorite guns.
Oh, yo.
Jez, what?
The ego!
Bro, he's egoing so hard.
I think Jez definitely has an ego there.
I've seen him land some of these.
Like, oh my god.
The aim assist on mobile has to be.
Yeah, I think he just...
There's like none.
He just tied it up, too.
Because I asked, I was the first...
I gave him my points.
You must be like, used to the aim assist, right?
And they're like, nah, there's like none.
I was like, oh my gosh.
Ah, I'm 10 times more.
Jez, what am I watching now?
Look at this.
Spam aiming.
Somebody asked, how does a 1v1 work in a team?
Well, they're representing their teams here.
So, whichever one of the team captains wins this one is going to take the second game.
Don't worry.
I'll vote for SpaceX.
Fool me once.
Shame on you.
Fool me twice.
I think if Jez continues, if Jez used the sniper, they would win this.
Honestly.
I honestly feel like Jez using the other gun is too much of an ego.
I think his sniper is better.
If you shoot me from behind, are you really better than me?
Like, if you shot me from behind, are you right?
Legit, he got six points with Jez sniper, so I don't understand.
You can't go up there.
Yeah, see?
That's how you judged skill back in the day, man.
That's how we judged.
Jez just needs to literally just use sniper and he wins this.
Definitely, like, slowed down, I feel like, for both these guys.
Okay, never mind.
That's fine.
First, like, ten kills on the board, five and five.
Jez, please, I just, Jez.
Oh, he's whiffing.
He's crashed.
He's whiffing.
He's crashing out.
Never mind.
Okay.
Caster's curse.
Now he whiffs.
Oh, is it cut up?
Oh, you guys don't see the score.
Yeah, it is cut off a little bit.
Don't worry, I'll tell you.
It's 11 to seven right now.
You need to keep Jez to run this.
Because Jez is momentum.
Oh, I'm stripping.
Yeah, you're right.
It's 11 to seven.
It's 12 to seven now.
Jez is kind of cooking right now.
Oh, yeah, they're scoring the top left, too.
Yeah, yeah, there's a score over there.
You guys don't need to see that.
You can see the score on top left.
Oh, he's like, where is he?
Where is he?
Okay.
Oh, he's locking in now, guys.
They're pretty good.
He's no longer egoing.
You'll see that happens a lot exactly like that.
Never mind.
The giant anchor that falls from the sky.
Not trying to make any sort of sound.
Caster's curse.
Oh!
I want to see that from the other angle.
Oh, I want the replay.
That movement was so good.
That's such a good movement.
That movement was insane there.
We've seen that happen a couple times.
in these 1v1s where someone's able just to hit some sort of jump over somebody else.
And it is just...
Oh!
Oh, I got it.
Normal kill.
Not cool.
It's very close.
Yeah.
Oh!
That flick was insane.
Oh my god.
I want to see...
I want to see the replay!
You beat the replay!
The fact that...
Yeah, this is all on the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
Oh, he's feeling it.
No!
He's closing the lead.
Only down two.
He's just playing too cocky again.
Oh, baby.
A tripper!
That was a...
Yeah, that was an insane flick.
Oh my god.
Wait, and then he got a nade kill there?
Uh, it might be a hunter killer drone.
It was, yeah.
It's all good.
I mean, yeah, that guy was playing...
That was a...
Wait, he got a...
A kill streak.
Wow.
Just like that.
Space takes the lead.
Guys.
He's heating up.
Hey, you got power.
Guys.
Who voted for Jez?
Who predicted Jez?
Oh, and he gets a pretty big drone!
Oh my god!
Bro!
Space got an odd retire!
Wait, he's choking!
He's...
Hahaha!
Yummy, yummy point.
No!
Should have been...
Should have been on the underdog.
Should have been on the underdog, guys!
Jez, please!
My doofy points!
Oh, it's getting close!
I blame your influence!
We got scammed!
Oh, it's tied, though!
Guys, it's tied!
Wait!
Wait, you still there's still hope!
Guys, why do you...
Guys, I manipulate...
I can easily manipulate the predictions.
What if I lied and he's not even retired?
You guys could have...
Liquipediated it.
Oh!
18 to 18!
Corden, you didn't even vote!
You have no say!
I looked at chat!
Chaz was like, you have no say!
You didn't even vote!
Oh!
Space, you're right, you're right!
Guys!
Oh, ho, ho, ho!
That would've been nasty!
He's trying to hit the flick!
Oh, ho, ho, ho!
It's so close!
Really wanted to make Jez play to him.
Kind of lame, but...
Hey, the dub's a dub.
Excuse him.
Jez has to play...
Oh!
He's just trying to wall bang it.
One minute left to go.
Space can win it here with a kill.
Oh!
That's so close!
Jez needs to hit one shot.
I am.
There's one minute left.
And Jez is...
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho!
Hit Marker.
Oh, my God!
Bro, Jez's movement!
Jez has to get a kill though, to tie this up!
Jez doesn't have much time.
40 seconds left.
Bro, bro, that movement is crazy.
I wonder what Jez's POV is though for this.
The problem though, Space knows exactly where he is, so he kind of does this check and...
Oh, here it is.
Here we go, here we go.
Oh, he doesn't sell!
He doesn't see him!
Oh!
Oh, no, he's...
Oh, he's just juking him!
Oh!
Got it!
Space takes it!
Let's go!
What a crutch!
Jez, oh!
Jez, you blew it!
Even that, you're talking about winning a...
The underdog!
Jez, you ruined me!
It's fail time, baby!
I know, yeah.
Fail time!
My goal!
Get going!
It's gonna be cold games though, I can't lie!
Choose outcome in space again!
All right!
How do they do that?
It's like...
It's just...
It makes...
It's actually genuinely...
That's how I'm saying...
You should...
Why?
It's like how people like...
Manipulate like...
The stocks by saying like...
Things that might not be true...
And why did you...
And it's like...
When he's using that...
Semi-auto type of...
It's just like...
The...
Your ability...
Oh, yep!
Now you know!
Hahaha!
There are people who like...
Imagine doubting space...
Inside a tree!
Jez, lock the...
Manipulate!
Hahaha!
All right!
All right, guys!
Next round!
Hahaha!
Next round, guys!
These...
Does anyone still believe in Jez?
Alright, well, hey!
Start prediction!
That's two really close...
Okay...
Jez...
Versus...
We still gotta...
Jez who will lock in!
Hahaha!
I'm trying to remind myself!
Maybe I'll...
I'll put it in five minutes!
Hey!
Yes!
And D!
Okay, I like that!
In search and destroy...
It's Jez...
There's still Jez believers!
Who is a Jez believer?
Right now!
Hahaha!
If you've seen...
Really anything...
I would...
Jez, I would still use my last minutes of points for you!
They have it in series all the time.
It's like a competitive map.
People love it.
So...
Obviously the...
The next game mode is search and destroy.
I'm helping out the squad of how they want to go ahead and play this.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I used to recap it on that map back then.
Let's see...
Let's see what it is.
Oh!
People are voting for space now!
Hahaha!
You're just like...
It'll be different!
Did I use the Galil?
I don't remember...
This is it!
Jez!
This is where you lock in!
Oh, oh, oh!
You was one of those!
You went up on that...
You went up on that ladder up top!
Oh, man!
Jez, you got this!
I feel like that once my friends started talking about KD...
I can't even highlight my message!
Yeah!
He's so...
You're so broke now!
I think there's a lot of...
I'm gonna be really curious.
Especially, obviously, we see, like, a bunch of snipers coming on out.
Like, we're gonna see people just, like, looking down range with a bunch of the snipers.
Just trying to be able to catch these people off.
But, let's just say, hypothetically...
Going down on the jet ship!
Hahaha!
You're like...
You're the captain that goes down...
With this ship.
You're like, this is it!
Hahaha!
Jez will eventually pick it up!
Okay, now, the real question for me is...
I can highlight my message just to laugh at that guy!
Yeah, I feel like if you remake it, like, twice, then it should be in the conversation.
Imagine losing your points for not believing in space!
It might...
Might be the most remade map we've had!
It's up there!
What?
Is it more than Nuketown?
Oh, it looks like a lot of Jez supporters have swapped over to space!
100%.
Nuketown, not in there.
But it might be up there.
That's a good shot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it definitely is fun to look at.
I think it's my favorite.
He didn't believe.
Is that crazy?
All those people that never believe in Jez, he's gonna prove you wrong!
Imagine going all in!
Hahaha!
No loyalty!
Those are the fake Jez Leavers!
Hahaha!
There's 53 Jez!
And 33 space!
But space stands are just richer!
What can I say?
The rich get richer, guys!
Sorry, Jez!
You failed me!
Fooled me once!
Shame on you!
Fooled me twice!
I love space now!
Hahaha!
I am a space stand now!
To six?
There's no round elevens.
Oh.
You play to seven, but you have to win by two.
So if you don't win by two...
That's so tough.
Yeah, it keeps going.
Oh, that's so crazy!
So it was 9-7 in the game.
That is momentum.
Alright, guys.
It could be final round.
That's tough.
Oh my god.
That's intense.
Yeah.
I think this is great.
Alright, here we go!
Who has been a space believer since the beginning?
Who has had a two out of two?
They're looking locked on in.
Up 2-0!
Let's see who's gonna take the sandbag challenge.
Oh, nobody took the sandbag challenge.
That's like...
Not me.
Hahaha!
Never!
Rated's been here before.
Oh!
Alright, let's see who gets the first kill.
It's search and destroy.
Wall bang right there.
Let's see.
Uh...
Oh!
Space lost the first...
First kill.
Oh!
Guys!
Just died!
Hahaha!
Guys!
He...
Hahaha!
You have enough time to have like how people started voting after the first game.
After the first match because there's no time.
People are like, okay, all in on space now.
Okay.
Hahaha!
They were smart.
Those people were smart.
Alright.
They waited until the first match.
The first round was over.
See, this is the nerd stuff that I was waiting for.
What are the hop ups?
What are the pre-nades?
Are you trying to hit these wall bangs?
You can see a lot of these players.
It's okay.
Bigger bonus.
They're trying to make their way over to this A site.
Jacob in the chat that he wants to see a hand.
Just support your silent right now.
Hahaha!
I like how the guy was like, no, I'm just crying.
I can't type with the tears in my eyes.
Please.
Your life.
Yeah.
Wait, wait.
Just got two though.
It's like throwing a shoulder.
Kinda looking in.
You got two people looking at you.
He gets taken out.
Oh!
Guys!
Wait!
Just leave it!
You have a chance!
They won a round!
Wait, hold on.
Just, just, just!
How many have you...
do you think you've hit?
I'm lying.
I haven't hit that one.
I threw them though.
All the time.
He tried.
This is it, guys!
Hahaha!
Oh, it's so close.
Oh, wait!
Space is almost...
Oh!
Space, don't you dare.
Best of luck for me!
That, it makes no sense.
I gotta stop, bro.
No, I ain't!
While I'm going down here, able to escape with his life.
Oh...
What's going on?
Oh, Space didn't take the shot.
Wait, is that not wall-bangable?
Oh, it's Space versus Earth.
Guys, what if, like, that first round was a bait all along?
All the people that waited till the last round to vote, till the first round to vote, you guys got baited.
Two down, hold on, wait.
Oh, unless...
Three down, wait.
He can't defuse.
Oh, oh, there's my phone.
I'll be right back.
At that point, he just did that, just for his own pride.
Try and reset, try and reset streaks.
Yeah.
And also just feel good.
Like, keep the fingers hot.
I'd like to see him maybe get one or two and then try and back up, maybe keep his own streaks, but...
Dude, you're getting hit markers on this every time.
Yo, Space is absolutely going crazy right now.
It's a good spot here.
Lucky.
I kind of like this.
What we see a lot of our creators do, they kind of, like, find this, like, they find a corner and they're just holding it.
They're waiting for somebody to run on by.
We've seen Aiden do it a number of times, where he's just kind of, like, literally preying on somebody just running forward, straight into his guns.
Here we go.
Rated pushing up here.
Maybe catching somebody off guard.
Yes, he does.
It's Noemi.
Good shot.
He's going to back the team up, too.
3v3 still.
Momentum.
Does have bomb planted.
Take down Aiden, but the trades are there.
Still a 2v2.
Last man standing.
Finish it.
Primrose.
1v1 against Jez.
Oh!
That's...
That's disrespectful.
That's just disrespectful.
Nasty jump shot.
Oh, God.
You only throw Rose out.
That's a heat check right there.
A jump shot.
Oh, God.
Wow.
Opportunity for Primrose to lock it on in.
Hopped on the bomb.
It's really all you can do in that moment.
Unfortunately.
You got Jez hitting shots like that.
It's going to be tough.
I'm loving this A side.
Everybody's really only playing A.
Is that space that just dropped?
Uh-oh.
That was.
Yeah, that's tough.
We can't even talk about the round.
It's a 4-1.
Wow.
That was round.
As soon as he said...
Wow.
As soon as space dropped...
Loki looked away.
I'm not going to lie.
When somebody's so dominant, though, you might as well just...
Your whole game plan needs to be just take them out first.
Yeah, yeah.
As soon as I get killed by him, I'm telling my whole team, let's get this training.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If I even see him on the map, I'm calm with that.
Yeah.
I got to make sure everybody knows where space is.
Alright, back on up.
Hey, we could see kind of a wrap.
Looks like they have cleared B.
Yeah, and I don't want to go for 3-4-3, but like, what would be the odds of a comeback here at 4-1?
I mean, hey.
It could happen.
I will say, though, this Momentum team has looked insane at Search and Destroy all day long.
Shots don't land.
Okay, still 3-4.
I mean, space has an opportunity to do something crazy.
I have the sun on my screen right now.
Yeah.
I don't really know what's going on there.
Okay, thank you.
Noemi gets dropped.
2v3 right now.
Aiden.
From long range.
There it is.
Wow.
5-1.
It's not over yet.
Absolute domination is what it is.
Michael, 2-1 on these calls.
Yeah.
Hey, you guys said 3-1, man.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, we did say 3-1.
We did say that.
Yeah.
See, that's my curse now.
Now the comeback starts.
Can't curse the curse, man.
There's limits.
I mean, I love this.
Jez just kind of throwing bullets.
What an angle there, too.
Like, what's the...
How would you even know who...
Good update.
That's all I can say.
I'll update later on Twitter.
But good update.
Oh, we got shot.
Good update.
I'm happy.
Not, like, mad.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, okay.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
Jez is winning?
Aw, man.
I should have kept believing.
Should have...
All the way in the back.
They can't hear us, right?
I would hope not.
I don't want to go home with nothing.
You shouldn't be able to.
You should have been more...
You should have believed in him.
Why didn't you believe in him?
I believe.
Is the comeback possible?
That's the question.
I mean, it starts here, right?
You just gotta take it one round at a time.
You're here now, back on offense.
And again, you're just kind of continually moving over towards this A site.
Everybody just flying their way on through.
Jez was zero.
Space was zero.
Yeah, but this is Jez's world.
This is his search and destroy.
Space.
Space please.
I have a family.
I need to pay rent.
Guys, what if I up the odds?
What if I make a point...
Make a redemption for VIP?
For the richest?
Just...
And I'll only give it to one person.
The real...
The gambling odds go up in prediction.
It goes up.
Now I'm interested.
Should have thought that.
Should have bet better.
Should have predicted better, guys.
Took a little too long there.
Yeah.
Space knew I placed a bet.
I tried.
That was your first mistake.
I used to be rich.
We increased the odds.
That's not fair.
Why didn't you mention it first?
Well...
Never bet against the house.
Never predict against the house.
Guys, one more point for...
One more point.
Jez just needs.
I can't go more down, bro.
So many people were ruined by Jez.
That's like one of those that you can do it.
He hits it?
Yeah, Aura.
Because he's farming it.
He's just...
He knows.
He heard about the prediction.
I'm going down straight away.
I like that.
See if he could escape with his life.
No, he's not even trying to.
Oh!
Maybe he should've.
He should've...
Why did he stay there?
Who was that guy?
Why?
Why did he stay there?
Gets one kill.
Grenade.
Oh!
It's Space versus Jez.
It's Jez.
Oh!
He's on the bomb.
Can you get him?
Oh!
What?
He won feet five!
He's tough.
Here's the thing.
That was crazy.
He's tough.
Make sure you go check.
Alright, now do that again like three more times.
He just has to do it three more times, guys.
It's a fluke.
The Jez Leavers are like, he can't do that again.
That's a fluke.
There's no way he'll do that again.
Okay.
Great start.
For Nebula Knights.
That's a risky angle hold.
Nah, this is his bot.
This is his domain.
Nobody goes into the space house.
If you're in my bad, man.
Oh.
They saw him.
They saw Aiden.
Unfortunately, Lucky doesn't win the fight.
Yeah.
Oh.
Wait.
It's getting close.
Oh.
He didn't hesitate.
Jez was just waiting.
Here's Jez.
Let's see if Jez can make something happen.
You know, 1v3.
This would be insane.
But we've also seen him do it literally here today.
Oh, it's close.
He just needs to kill space.
Of the Knights.
They're playing on this bomb side.
He's gonna go ahead and check.
Oh.
He's...
He got it.
He won.
It's over.
Space should not...
I don't know why.
Oh.
It's over.
It's...
He sees it.
The shots.
It misses.
Oh.
Space choked that.
Why did Space plant the bomb?
What?
There it is.
Is this what winning feels like to the Jez leaders?
My code is washed.
Yeah.
Wow.
I can see a lot of scores.
I just...
I saw a lot of...
Now they know what winning feels.
Loyalty to the end.
You were loyal to the end.
You were loyal to the end and you were rewarded for it.
Yeah.
I don't know what to say.
It's like a different person's plan.
Space kind of run around.
Maybe they were thinking like this movement is the best.
So he can squeeze his way out of the situation.
Maybe.
Back to the mind.
Yeah.
Even the intel.
All right.
I said Jez who will lock in.
I did write that.
Here's game three right here.
Who would have thought?
I mean, I think you guys hit it on the head.
We did.
Space and Jez.
Yeah.
I like how Blazing was like, I lost 120 points.
Oh, Blazing.
There were a lot of points that were lost.
I think someone lost more.
I am pretty sure.
I lost 10k.
Is the other thing.
Is that like, that isn't just how we won the search and destroy.
No, we won this convincingly.
Yeah.
It kind of feels very...
Crying about 120?
If they have it here, if they can squeeze out a hard point, they should hopefully be feeling pretty good on that game.
All right.
More prediction, guys.
Let's see.
I was hoping to see something a little bit different.
You know what?
Space...
Takes a bath.
I like how Space baited a lot of you guys too.
In the first round, he baited all of you.
For the people who've waited until the match started.
And was like, oh yeah, Space is definitely gonna win this.
Aw, there were...
At least like 20k points were...
Were voted extra.
There's no...
Yeah, there's like the water on the outside.
Yeah.
I don't think you can swim in the water.
And there's no like, out of bounds fence hop that we see today in like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It kind of like shrinks the map a little bit.
This is the house money now.
The next game mode is hard point.
Yeah.
It's hard point.
I'ma let you...
God baited so hard.
We'll see it, but...
Man, I mean, as we get ready to hop on into the hard point...
Also Nomad, thank you for the 80 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Pretty close.
Until it wasn't.
Until...
Buy yourself something nice.
To all...
To all the people that lost on space.
It's not true.
God gate...
Look at that.
God gate is like...
Buy yourself something nice.
That's true.
Yeah.
Hey, that's passing.
Yeah, that's true.
I'm glad it's a good series though.
Like, I came in kind of with expectations, but...
All three games have been closed.
Yeah.
It's just a matter of who's been able to close out.
And here we go.
We got map number four.
All right.
It's hard point.
Here we go.
Hacienda hard point.
Space did win this one, guys.
Yeah.
Of course.
Space won this one though.
Currently up two maps to the momentum one.
Here we go.
P1 gonna be that fountain right in the middle.
Oh, that's good already.
Oh.
Wait.
Oh my God.
That was...
Wait, who got the...
Oh, Jez got the initial point.
So you're gonna have a lot of your teammates drop, unfortunately, to a bunch of team kills, which you hate to see, but...
Really, the thing here, P1, it's a scrub.
Oh, people are waiting.
Everyone's waiting until the last second of the vote right now.
Everyone's like, I'm not.
I need to know for sure.
This is for VIP.
This is...
Cow.
Hold.
And if you were like, you don't believe in them, you coward.
Coward.
Pretty...
Pretty low score after P1, which we kinda go ahead and we expect, but...
You're gonna see there it's that bottom left as it comes on line.
You're really trying to hold this on in, make this mixy.
Remember the people who waited last time and they lost?
I'm a coward!
I lost so much!
Man, okay.
Nebula Knight.
They actually...
They got fights.
They let you get back on the point.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, shit.
Uh-oh.
They're desperate, guys!
They're desperate!
I see them here.
Oh, it's really close.
Oh, you can't even tell.
Cleared it out.
There's space again.
He's doing it again.
Oh!
It's close, though!
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Being able to fight back and forth.
That's what you love to see.
They feel nice.
They're still gonna have a lot of these close spawns, though.
So they're just gonna keep hitting this one out if they can.
Still plenty of time to fight.
No, it's 30.
What the gap is getting?
Alan, are you okay?
It's 34 to 35.
What do you mean?
The last remaining seconds on the hill.
You are cowards, and this is why S3 will forget you.
Wait!
Space is taking the lead right now!
I've already spawned on over here.
You got three members.
If Alan loses, I just vote against Alan every time.
Is that it?
Wait, Alan is 0-3.
Wait!
Okay, who's won all their bets so far?
Who's won all?
Who's got three out of three?
It's like the...
Remember like in the...
In the...
In the FIFA World Cup, there was the prediction squid?
Or the prediction octopus?
Who's our prediction octopus?
Like that war machine, the grenade launcher.
It's just...
Overpowered.
That is crazy, man.
Well, I mean, think about breaking points, right?
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna talk about it.
Yeah, Paul the octopus!
Where are you?
The flank there from rated.
He's feeling right at home on this map.
100%.
Wait, who did Alan bet?
Did Alan bet for Jez or Space?
Let's check.
Well, I feel like hitting old right now and I don't necessarily know...
Okay, Alan voted for Space.
Trying to get some of this, you know, last final two or three seconds.
This rock hill, you can really hold on to and start to either pull away a lead or get back into the game on.
So, if I'm momentum right now, I would be fighting tooth and nail for this rock hill.
This is exactly what you like to do.
No!
Alan!
Swap your boat right now!
They're gonna lose their life savings!
Oh!
That's Peyton Manning who lopped that.
Right in the pocket.
He's the reverse ball.
Yeah.
Oh, this course should lose one.
Oh, he sold the sword.
He's lopped the octopus.
Lopped the squid.
That's the thing.
You can get the specialist, but I don't know what you do with it.
Yeah, you got it.
Lopped the squid.
Good shots.
Jez, are you playing the front side?
At that point, you're just like, alright, whatever.
Here for the people for that one.
That's a good trade, though.
Like, I'll take myself out of it for me and Jez.
Jez also goes with me, bro.
It's been pretty mixy of a P4.
Oh, they took down space.
It's so close.
Jez did a great job.
Oh, my God, man.
He's applying so much pressure.
Can he keep going?
Yes!
Wait, he's out of killstreak.
Give him the streaks.
He gave him a streak.
Jez!
Absolutely slaying in this one.
Oh, my God.
Wait, he has to keep living.
I mean, Jez is, Jez is like, has the most kills currently.
That was a good reference, man.
He has takeover.
Someone locked in.
Space!
I need my VIP!
I think he's gonna hold on to that predator missile for when they need to open up one of these hills.
Probably P4 or P3.
That's, you know, way more wide open.
Oh, he's throwing two aggressive on that?
Yeah.
That's a good trade.
Not gonna lie, Jez has been performing.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
There they go, that war machine.
Yo!
That's what I'm picking up.
Yup.
I'm so anxious.
I thought about that first hard point.
Alan, didn't you vote for Jez at first?
For the first round?
What happened?
Oh, now you say kills don't matter?
Weren't you a Jez, Jez lever?
Hey,
maybe space will win, guys.
Game for them, not too crazy.
No, I'd be trying to hold the angle.
No, he's shot.
Yes, maybe space will win this.
Space, so composed.
Let's see if you can hold it down.
One.
There's the laser.
What the heck is that gun?
Wait, that's cheating!
Aiden's war machine finally finding some kills there.
What?
Does he have like a spear?
What is he holding?
Oh, that's a kill streak gun?
Oh, my God.
Ready to clean it up.
That's huge.
I was like, what is he holding?
Honestly, I feel like they were afraid to answer because space had...
Yeah!
I was like, bro, that guy brought a gun from the future!
How is that fair?
Someone told me he had the Tempest.
I'm waiting outside.
40 point lead?
Yeah, but remember who else had a 40 point lead before they lost?
Super good job of really just kind of creating that lead.
You're putting a lot of pressure on momentum right now.
I mean, if they play this good, they play this good.
Fuck you, Alan.
I've been against you and I'm gonna lose!
Yeah, momentum.
Down 50 in this one so far, but they do have control of the hill.
He's just...
Everyone's just like, let's see where Alan voted.
And then make sure to vote against him.
Oh, but...
But...
Jez does have the point right now.
Oh, no, he has...
Oh, it's the kill streak!
Oh!
Wait, who did he kill?
Okay, it's okay.
Jez is still alive.
Oh, never mind.
Wait, no.
Jez is still alive.
Where's the point?
Oh...
Looks like there's one player from momentum that has made some sort of read.
So you're gonna get some...
He's dead.
Never mind, he's dead.
And get ready to pop in the next couple of seconds.
So you're able to set yourself on...
And it's a 60-point lead.
Our momentum.
But we saw this last time around.
Maybe the Knights did a great job breaking it off.
Toki, you gave me false information.
The house always wins in the end.
Still though.
60 points.
You literally have to play.
Perfect.
You pulled it out.
I was a coward and I will be rewarded.
Jez, are you really gonna let the cowards win?
Dev.
And if your momentum right now, this is the last thing you wanna see.
Nebula Knights has the ability to run away with it here.
30 seconds left on the hill.
They need to break it.
At least you need to at least protest it.
Oh, it doesn't look so good.
They're just being mowed down right now.
They're being mowed down over and over and over again.
Continuing to slide around.
they're feeling good all day long.
They're just trickling in.
Yeah, walking in the shots.
Yeah good shots there from Santana.
What the world is for the cowards?
Who is the one that...
Who was the one?
That was mad at the cowards?
Who was it?
That was yelling at them.
Who did you vote for?
It was me, and he voted for Jez!
The angry man voted for Jez, too.
Yeah, let's go take a look at his S25.
Expeditiously.
Here we go.
Flank here from space.
I take you with honor!
So, in that situation, why not just chill in the balcony with your Tempest and gun him down?
He's probably just trying to create space for his team, because at least if he can get a couple of kills off the hill, really get them out, you can let the rest of his teammate flood in.
Guys, I don't think they're going to get the points back, guys.
I don't!
As soon as I have a Tempest and I want kills.
He's playing aggressive.
I want to use this before it runs out.
Definitely a valid thing to try and do.
Okay, here we go.
Yep, this hill is very, very important.
Momentum needs...
Here we go.
They do have control of it so far here.
He has the grenade launcher, but he needs to know where they are.
They need as many points as they can get.
Oh!
Okay, so getting all of these kills is so much right now.
He needs those kills as much as he can.
One in the back.
Hunter killer's there.
He's still alive.
He's healing.
He's operating.
I... Oh!
Two piece.
Nope, just hit one.
The spawn protection.
How?
Can his team, like, guard in time?
Death machine online.
Okay, momentum.
Yeah, this is exactly what he's doing here.
His team needs to be able to guard... guard in time.
While he's out.
They have control of this hill and...
They have made an unrealistic comeback look a lot more realistic.
Wow, they did everything they needed to.
Oh no, he got Husker!
Yep.
Turn around!
Cut them on down.
They're not expecting you to be on over here.
Oh, 175.
Oh.
Space just needs 30 points, guys.
Anybody there?
Space has a...
Temptions in his back pocket.
Just 30 points.
Space got a kill though!
Space got two!
Oh!
They could close out here.
They could.
They could!
20!
Already, you can see the members of...
Momentum, they're spawning in the back.
Sandwich.
The last final...
Oh!
They got the point back!
They got it back!
Everybody's still just trying to run at this hill.
Still...
He has to be able to control this for...
Oh my god.
Oh, it's tight.
They're on the hill.
Wait, but space is...
35!
36!
Oh!
No, it's gonna take another hill.
Yup, not just yet.
Great contest.
It's to P4.
They're still contesting.
It's the rock hill.
They've been so good at it throughout this entire...
They're still contesting.
Jez is still...
Oh!
37!
38!
39!
It's at 39!
He needs 11 points!
Cowards win!
Already lucky!
Holding this one on in!
Should've been a coward, guys!
Should've been a coward!
They do it!
They break the hill!
They have it!
You're still getting close spots now!
Oh, this is a shot!
That was a huge pitch by Santana.
And if they could do what they did earlier all over again, and milk this hill for all this time...
They are...
I milked the hill!
Oh, Jez is down!
Jez is down!
It's over!
Guys!
Jez is down!
Oh!
Three!
The shots are there!
Do they line on up for you?
46!
Wow!
Oh, but the whole team...
You're still close!
Oh!
Jez is down!
It's over!
Wait!
But he got...
They got space!
49!
50!
They've seen that!
Wow!
That was good!
Oh my god!
They got up!
40!
I'm not lost anymore!
I'm not!
What?!
That's close!
Yo!
It's rule of the world!
Put the team on it's back, man!
Congratulations!
It looks like space one in the end!
Look at them!
They're stoked!
They're excited!
They're working together!
Give me that!
I'm a coward, but I'm rich!
Oh my god!
Not washed no more!
He never took a bath!
Look at that!
801k!
Definitely!
Definitely a hard fought win!
3-1!
You have called me good!
Jesus!
Look at him go!
On the!
Exclamation point!
Samsung!
Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra!
That was a good game!
That was a natural good game!
Wow!
Congratulations to Nebula Knights!
I always trusted in space!
Many!
Thank you for this super chat!
Uh, think of- Not super chat!
Thank you for the 250s!
Thank you!
At least with my current phone!
I can't see my losses as clearly as I would have!
With this Samsung S25!
Alright!
Wait!
Who has 100% prediction rate?
Guys!
Who at?
Got it!
Alright!
Let me make this!
I don't know if- Let me see if anybody actually has enough for this!
I'm actually curious!
What a match though!
Geez!
That was an intense game!
What an intense match!
Alright!
Let's see!
Power up and channel points!
Uh...
Is it rewards?
Oh, it is rewards, right?
No!
It's power up and channel points!
Okay!
Enable!
Customize!
Alright!
Let's see!
Where is it?
Uh...
Add a new custom reward!
Get VIP!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Somebody needs a blazer!
Alright!
Let's see!
Yeah!
He still has an opportunity!
VIP!
We could come back in our show match!
You could still walk away!
Let's see if anybody has enough for this!
After all the prediction!
Let's see the people who got...
4 out of 4!
Socks, thank you for the 1,000 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Space is the GOAT.
Alright.
How do I... okay, redemption, cooldown limits.
Limit redemption, one.
One, alright.
There's only one redemption for this.
But let's see if anybody... for space...
Always believed in... always believe in the underdog.
Space!
Alright, I'm curious, because I know some people won 100k, so let's see...
Let's see how many people... how many actually... let's see if anybody can afford this.
Alright, it's on.
Can anyone afford this?
That Mr. Bass from the past is live on the stage right now.
Ready to interview our win...
No way!
Fire... I'm curious.
Alright, we've got our winning team one more time.
Give it up for the Nebula Knights!
Too rich for my blood.
There has to be one... one of you guys must... must have... must be able to afford it, right?
Congratulations one more time!
Surely, one of you guys could afford it!
We're all... we've bet it all on Jez!
I've bet it all on Jez!
I don't have enough!
Alright, alright, since we don't... I lost everything!
One more time, you're winners of the Samsung Galaxy Gear Up Cup!
Yay!
Alright, I'm lowering it.
I have lowered it.
Surely!
Someone!
Could've...
I believe!
Surely!
You guys want enough predictions for it!
My guy!
Do you mind stepping over here?
We gotta talk!
Raise it instead!
There's only one redemption for it!
First off, a massive congratulations!
You drafted a team that has not only taken this entire thing home!
You guys did...
Space was...
Wait, Space was the vibes guy!
He also did vibes!
A 3-2-1 in the brands!
That guy...
I remembered!
He spaced it off of vibes!
It was vibes!
It's all team work!
And I mean...
If you look to the draft...
It was vibes to the end!
It was the worst team!
But they had no clue!
They absolutely had no clue what was in store!
My team showed up.
They were practicing!
They were ready!
And that's just what's gonna take the game!
Alright, I'll do one more!
I'll do one more!
Cause I saw someone said...
They have 250k...
So I put it at 260k...
CK.
That's crazy!
The last one.
You monster!
Clearly someone can redeem this one.
Screw that one... one Dragoon in particular.
Surely, right?
You know what?
Also, congratulations to space!
Oh, that's a nice metal, by the way.
That metal looks pretty sick.
All right, guys.
You're a monster.
All right.
I'll give you... I'll give him one chance to make enough, guys.
I'll give you guys one chance to make enough to be able to afford it.
Heads or tails.
He might win it all or lose it.
He could win it all or lose it right here.
Heads or tails.
You could be able to afford it here.
Yeah, that's the best.
Hi, my name is Space, and today I'm going to be giving y'all some COD mobile tips and tricks specifically about the importance of scorestreaks.
When competing at any level, scorestreaks can literally be the difference between winning and losing a game.
Scorestreaks are also known to have a huge snowballing effect when used correctly, so let's go ahead and look at some of the specifics.
There's only three main scorestreaks.
Don't worry, I got the coinflip right here.
The Pred Missile and the EMP system.
These scorestreaks were specifically chosen for comp because they're known to not have that big of a snowball effect, but there's still a few key tips and tricks that y'all should consider when using them.
With the Pred Missile, a lot of people will literally just spam their screen as fast as they can until it lands.
That's true, though.
He was really good with his...
He was really good with his, like, killstreak weapons.
What players do is whenever they use a Pred Missile, they'll let it fall extremely slow, and instead of mashing the screen trying to get a kill, they'll actually call out where all the enemies are.
Don't do it.
Alright.
I'm flipping the coin.
The EMP system, it's best to talk to your teammates and use it in tandem with their operator skills.
The EMP systems actually destroy all trophy systems.
So if you have a teammate with a war machine or a skill, have them tell you when it's ready, and then pop the EMP as soon as they pop their operator skills, and that'll ensure that they don't have to worry about a single trophy system.
The ranked, on the other hand, there is absolutely zero restriction on what scorestreaks you can use.
Me, personally, I like to get a lot of kills in my game, so I choose to use non-ranked scorestreaks that are mainly informative.
My scorestreaks of choice are the UAV, the Shock RC, and the Advanced UAV.
If you go on the street high enough to get an Advanced UAV, it basically gives you mathpacks showing exactly where every single enemy is on the other team.
No, you didn't!
He picked Tails!
But if we're getting serious, and you're actually trying to win some ranked games, I would highly recommend you all use the UAV, the Dragonfire Drone and the Goliath.
These three scorestreaks just work so well together, you use your UAV to get some information, and with that information you get the Dragonfire Drone.
Once you use the Dragonfire Drone, have your teammates protect you, and shoot your bullets to tag the enemies on the map.
Now you can see the enemies through the world, and with the case that you get from having these wall hacks, you'll be able to get your Goliath.
These are literally the cheapest, easiest, and most effective scorestreaks to use in rank.
And if you really, really want to win those ranked games, I would highly recommend y'all use these.
Anyways guys, I hope that y'all can take some of these insights and apply them to your own game.
Oh!
I got John got it!
John got it!
Thanks for the, thanks for the tips, space.
Congratulations!
John!
The one pull I lost!
The one pull he lost!
That's crazy!
And so unlucky!
John has received the VIP!
That's fate intended!
Alright, roles manager.
Add new.
VIP.
Congratulations!
You have received!
You have received VIP!
You, you overtook Delta's VIP for it.
Alright, now let me close this.
The one time, I just, I wanted to have a little fun.
Into the chair you go, Delta.
Wait, John, what was your prediction rate?
John, what was your prediction rate?
How many times did you get it correctly?
Too much pack.
Wait, was this in his first one that he got correct?
Correct?
Oh my god, that's dope!
Oh, and won all three.
Oh, he had a hundred percent win rate!
He had a hundred percent prediction rate!
Oh, he was a true Paul the Octopus.
He was Paul the Octopus!
No way!
We should have all listened to him!
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
Delta was the fa- Del-Del-Del-Del was the false prophet all along!
Sir Jet, thank you for the hundred bitties!
Thank you, thank you!
In the end, Del-Del-Del was the false prophet!
You're actually so evil!
Darkflame, thank you for the hundred bitties!
Thank you, thank you!
You were so close!
So close!
So, that was fun!
I don't know, in the end, I think in the end, I definitely had the most fun with these predictions!
As we all know, the house always wins!
Viva Las Vegas!
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
But yeah!
Let me double check real quick!
I didn't know if I have to...
Because I know they have show matches!
So I want to make sure if we are doing show matches or not!
Uh...
But yeah, that was really fun though.
I hope you guys enjoy it!
Thank you again to Samson for, you know, the experience and watching the finals there.
I'm just gonna make sure, because I know they do have show matches after, so I want to be sure that if we're watching show matches or we raid into the show matches.
Uh, but Rysox, thank you for the 2,000 biddies!
Thank you, thank you!
Prediction stream, guys.
It was a prediction stream.
We're just having fun.
We're having fun watching Space vs.
Jez.
That's crazy though, because like, I think Space was the underdog throughout all of that.
Because like, he retired.
He did retire, like, earlier.
He retired last year.
And Jez was like, actively competing too.
So, um, it was, it was actually like, like, the odds were against him.
I had fun, but some goons are eating ice water now.
Some dragoons have lost their house.
I had fun though, guys.
I don't know about you guys, but I had fun.
Some would never, never tell me about the odds again.
Um...
Oh my god.
Who's broke right now?
Who's broke and who's rich?
I wanna know.
Who has...
Who...
Who has a lot of...
Who has made bank?
And who has lost everything?
Sir Jet, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my gosh, I like...
Confusing biddies and super chats.
I lost everything.
Oh husband, you better lost all 67k.
Now we are homeless.
I have 200 points, smile.
I'm at...
Wait, you're at 272 Sean?
Why didn't you claim the VIP?
Sean!
You could have had it!
Oh, John clicked...
John was faster.
He didn't want it.
He's classy.
See...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
He's still there...
...for our final event of the day.
A 1v1 to determine it all.
We already saw our grand finals...
I want, I'm waiting to see if...
Uh...
If we are watching the show matches or not.
I'm not sure though.
I'm not sure.
We'll watch like...
We'll watch like one round.
And then we'll call it here.
Let me double-check.
I'll double-check real quick, guys.
Wow!
Destination point Samsung, guys!
With a Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
The improved cooling system means you can game for longer without worrying about overheating.
And it's a match made in the stars only...
Time, we use the bathroom, and then I'll double-check.
I'll be right back!
...to Samsung Galaxy for this entire event.
This is, after all, the Samsung Galaxy Gear Up Cup.
But it is time for us to invite, for the final time tonight, our captains of our grand finalists to the stage.
Let's welcome Jez and Space!
Well, I know both of you are not only professionals at this point, but you've probably been here for some interviews before, but now we're gonna make it a little different.
No?
All right, well, then this will be a first, so I'm gonna let you talk a little bit of trash.
First, I have to go to the winner of our grand final.
Look, there's no secret here.
You guys have already faced off in a 1v1.
It was very close.
How are you gonna do the same thing twice?
I don't know.
I'm scared.
I feel like whenever he had a lead, he, like, let his foot off the gas, and then whenever I caught up, he put it back on.
So I feel like this one, he's going full throttle.
I have no clue what to expect.
Well, it sounds like your opponent doesn't really know what to expect, but you probably have a little bit of a game plan.
You've had some chance to get some revenge at this point, so what are you gonna do to get your revenge?
Just win.
Just win is not the worst strategy I have ever heard.
It is three 1v1s, though, at this point here.
One thing we did see in your quarterfinal, or I guess semifinal, is you switched the shotguns.
Any plan on doing that again?
Probably not this one, no.
Gonna keep it all serious, fair enough.
Any tricks up your sleeve at this point, or is it business as usual, sniper in hand, AR in the other?
Same thing.
Alright, it sounds like there's no funny business at this point, so gentlemen, I will say, get to your stations, and good luck to the both of you.
Alright, that is Jez and Space, our finalists here.
The grand finals has concluded, but now it is time for our $15,000 show match.
Let's throw it to the casters and get ready for our final fight.
Thank you so much, Mr. Bass from the past, we are here, final moments.
I'm back!
I'm back, guys.
Oh, let me see.
Alright!
Alright, guys, so, I'm...
So this is the end of my portion of the stream, but I will raid into the official broadcast.
For those who want to continue watching...
Oh, it's Jez versus Space.
For those who want to continue watching, I will raid into the final show match.
Thank you, everybody, for coming!
And huge shoutout to Samsung again.
This entire tournament, the Galaxy Gear Up Cup was powered by Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra and presented by Samsung.
So again, huge shoutout to them for allowing me to do this official co-stream.
For them, please check, exclamation point, Samsung out.
Check the phone out as well, Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra.
This entire tournament was run by... on the phone.
So like, on the exact phone.
So everything you saw, the gameplay and everything.
It's actually crazy, the things they could do with all of that.
And we had a lot of fun!
I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching today's stream.
And, you know, if you want to stay here, stay to watch the final show match.
Just stay in the channel, and then I'm going to raid it into that.
And thank you, everybody!
It was always really fun to do these sponsor stream with you guys.
I feel like it doesn't even feel like a sponsor stream.
And we had so much fun doing these types of stuff together.
And just hanging out and everything.
And I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching with me.
And checking out mobile gaming for the first time, like mobile esports for the first time.
And yeah, I'm glad you guys enjoyed it.
But I had so much fun, and I had so much fun watching you guys lose all your points.
The house always wins.
Or win them, you know?
Okay, my favorite moment was when I priced the points, the $260k for the VIP.
And then just see like, just see DelDelta lose it all.
It was just within, it was within, like, it was just there.
Just lose it all on the one last prediction.
Mehdi, thank you for the 200 biddies, thank you, thank you.
Anything else about the phone call?
Well, just, um, it was good.
The surgery went great, like, went great.
And yeah, that's really all I can say.
I'll talk more about it next time on the...
You wasn't shambles, you monster.
Just right there.
The last 50-50.
Oh, sorry, I thought you meant the phone call.
Oh, the phone!
Oh, yes, so...
My favorite part about the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra was the fact that, you know...
Like I said, it's on 120Hz.
So, I think that is my favorite part.
Just for the fact that it is, it has 120Hz refresh rate.
Uh, which for me is, like, really good for a phone, especially if you're, like, into mobile gaming.
Or, like, just, like, you know, having better refresh rate, better frames, in general.
Like, that's, like, the one thing that I always look for in terms of, like, gaming as well.
Um, and, uh, and also the fact that it does run, like, it ran Call of Duty Mobile so well.
Like, um, yeah, 4.47, uh, um, GHz of processor.
Like, it ran this game so well.
Like, you can see the graphics and everything.
Like, was really smooth and stuff.
Like, with how intense the gameplay was.
Uh, but yes, thank you again to Samsung.
Um, this entire tournament was presented by Samsung, um, and, uh, powered by Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra!
Exclamation point of Samsung to please check it out.
Hey, guys!
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!
I'm gonna raid to this channel, so, to the Samsung, uh, US channel.
So you guys can watch the show match if you want to.
Uh, but I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye-bye!